did you ever think you make
IET Victory I know this life for
me why would you better on Goliath when
we got bet David value taming giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters how run homie
look what I
[Music]
become
2024 is here happy New Year everybody
hello uh we have on a podcast for God
knows how long now by the way this has
been two weeks it's almost been two
weeks I
forgot good to meet you Tom
pleasure
Vinnie Vinnie I hope you had a happy New
Year we haven't been doing this for a
couple weeks there's a lot of stories to
cover we were out of town uh crazy stuff
happened where we were at when we were
at Aspen we went to a movie theater
literally the movie theater's called
Isis movie theater no joke we'll tell
you about it we'll show you the picture
of it and then uh uh all of a sudden
we're out on the Mountain skiing you
know snowboarding let me rephrase the
statement attempting to snowboard
it SS little toal and I get a text and a
video from Mario thinking this is a joke
like they hired somebody from the city
to come and save this deer's life and
then next thing you know know Mario
literally saves the deer's to the point
where by the way stop it I'm not I'm
actually not kidding with you the entire
city knew about it no no hear me out the
owner of the house shows up says we just
want to thank on behalf of the city for
you guys saving the deer's life the next
day 200 elks have an emergency
meeting the house I have the video I'll
show you all this
stuff you'll see maybe it was a clip
from the movie unbeliev I don't leave
the world I don't believe Mario's
capable now all all of that stuff that's
going on all that stuff that's going on
yesterday I posted a tweet middle of the
night everybody sticks me P what
happened what happened what happened I
said look it's only day one and it's
already validation that this is going to
be the year of chaos did you see this
the the South Korea presidential
candidate getting St the
crowd a guy runs up in a crowd the
moment you posted that the moment you
posted that I just made a quick list
right so we're day one right a passenger
plane exploding on the runway in Tokyo
did you guys see that five people killed
a car filled with explosives plowing
into a New York uh New York crowd in New
York City tsunamis across Asia
earthquakes in Asia and the California
high it's dude 2024 we're coming in hard
by the check this out you ready there
was one earthquake over 7.0 1 over 6.0
13 over 5 84 over4 179 over 3 235 over2
RoR skill just yesterday just yesterday
so all of this stuff that's happening is
it's got a lot of people concerned this
is why for me I the listen the number
one affirmation for everybody this year
should be future looks bright simple as
the number one affirmation for anybody
that follows the pbd podcast should be
future looks bright and that's why we're
doing this only today for this podcast
because this it's New Year's first
podcast we're doing you order a one of
these hats which R you have it up there
right there so we can give this to the
entire audience before we going to all
our stories you order one of these hats
I want this gear sported everywhere with
future looks Sprite we're going to throw
in another hat on the house and another
shirt future looks bright on the house
you can buy whatever else you want but I
want everybody this year wearing the Hat
future looks bright because it shocks
the crap out of everybody because when
chaos happen when scary times happen
they want you to be afraid they want you
to shiver chaos cannot stand it when
it's scary times and a group of people
decide to stand up towards it and say
how the hell am I not scaring you how am
I scaring everybody else but not you
you're going to say because I believe
ready the future
lookss period so the the code for this
Rob what is the code for this you said
pbd podcast 2024 all one word lower case
so can you put that in the description
as well for people to order Gord hat
future look Sprite pbd podcast before
put it all together you'll get a second
hat for free and you'll get a future
looks bright shirt for free it's like
$70 free stuff I'm throwing over to you
just today this is a only one day pbd
podcast order thing we're doing Tom you
know last year 2023 you boldly said and
it was absolutely correct that 2023
would be the year of Investigations yep
that's what happened and now you're
saying 2024 the year chaos I hope you're
wrong but boy yesterday started with a
bang oh it's pretty I don't think I'm
going to be wrong I think it's going to
be crazy but I'm telling you right now
I'm I think you're right I I wish it was
different I think you're right no so
last night Jennifer was laying next to
me says babe didn't you call this year
the Year of chaos what the hell is going
on I said babe here's how you got to
look at this when you want to build
muscle you need the most resistance
period that's how you get tougher this
is going to be a year of resistance just
know you're going to be pushed and
challenged and bullied and you have to
stay bulletproof strong confident
optimistic cuz your family your friends
your relatives your co-workers your
peers the people that report you the
people report to you everybody's going
to need a level of optimism and
confidence going into this year it is
going to be weird I'm not going to Sugar
C code it for you it's going to be very
weird I have a whole different thing
already written for 2025 but we still
to absolutely 2025 so life is going to
put a bunch of plates on the having said
that gang go place the order future
looks bright let's sport it tag me tag
us we'd share a bunch of it as well with
uh our community okay stories to get
into large number of Americans you ready
want a strong rough anti-democratic
leader what a title right there right
they want a strong rough anti-democratic
it's almost like you know you could have
replaced a large number of women won a
strong rough anti-democratic husband but
the title is actually large number of
Americans want a strong rough
anti-democratic leader talk about that
Nikki Haley I got a message for you
Nikki halia as Trump's VP she doesn't
reject idea says they would work well
together we'll talk about that Marine
become second state uh uh Maine I'm
sorry Maine become second state to ban
uh Trump from 2024 ballot Tom's got some
thoughts on that uh California Secretary
of State refuses to remove Trump from
the ballot California becomes First
State Ready folks this is exciting news
right if you want to move to California
to offer health insurance to all
undocumented immigrants how awesome is
that is that great you know what that's
kind of like working at Google
headquarters or Apple and apple becomes
the first company in the world to offer
non-employees badges to come in what a
noble thing to do America California
Nome what a sweetheart of a guy you are
Canada Praises law requiring tampons in
mail bathroom cuz you know we need it
that's what matters dude he knows that's
a leader a lead there's only one
bathroom that needs that us us boxing to
allow trans women to compete against
other female boxers so us boxing is now
allowing trans women to compete oh oh
yeah and wait till you hear what what
they have to go through to do it Travis
Kelce is officially the champion of game
day advertising kicking everyone's but I
know you got something to say about that
yeah la office building sells for $535
million $15 million less than its sale
price a decade ago the question is do do
the bathrooms in that building have
tampons that's what I'm concerned if
they do or not diversity equity and
inclusion programs took a hit in 2023
fair f Forbes favorite 2023 Forbes what
happened to you honestly what the hell
happened to you I got a message for
Dylan mulany you have at one of your
events the best celebrity interviews of
the Year
seriously absolutely pathetic by the way
check this one out this is from USA
Today this is not Fox a Frank Coalition
black Hispanic young voters abandon
Biden as election year begins when you
abandon you leave him for somebody else
who are they going to I don't know we're
going to find out Democrats mayor
Chicago New York Denver uh reach
breaking point from migrant surge White
House says border surge not usual it's
just you know some normal stuff that's
going on of course nothing big going on
uh Bill Clinton to be unmasked as doe 36
and identified more than 50 times in
Jeffrey Epstein's doc dump do you have
that one video with Epstein's brother or
you know trying to get that file if you
don't have it I'll send it to you Jes
this this news is going to break some
people's hearts so you may want to skip
this one or ear muffs um beer drinking
in America fell to the lowest points
this Century at budlight boycott tough
year for beer okay and so again I have a
good I have a good thing for you should
use that all right so here's the next
one folks if you're Ultra Rich to to all
these rich greedy people check this out
Ultra Rich by Ultra Luxury you ready
what word you think comes afterward
housing cars vacation home no luxury
counseling gets kid kids into Harvard
you know how much you're charging we'll
tell you about it here in a minute for
happen for happiness in a New Year stop
overd doing everything Wall Street
Journal Adam's got some uh wisdom to
share with us on that story he he's
going to give those in a few minutes
here so having said that let's get into
one of our stories which story do we
want to get into uh I think rob you were
talking about the audience wants to do
Epstein let's go into that one Bill
Clinton to be un mask as doe 36 and
identified more than 50 times in
Epstein's doc dump the this is a New
York Post story Rob if you can find that
clip as well that'd be great if not I'll
text it to you when I pass it over to
somebody so uh Bill Clinton be
identified as John do 36 in court
documents linked to Jeffrey libin's case
appearing more than 50 times in the
records related to Virginia's
2015 lawsuit the reference largely
concerns efforts to compel Clinton to
testify against epon and galain Maxwell
no illegal activity by Clinton is
expected to be indic in indicated
in the documents the unsealed documents
are expected to reveal over 170
individuals with ties to Epstein
including accusers alleged victims and
those associated with his inner circle
prince Andrew uh Accused by Virginia as
well of sexual involvement is one of the
notable names of documents may also
include testimony from Jane Doe 162
about a 2001 party at Epstein's
townhouse where Virginia alleged she was
introduced she was instructed to to have
sex with prince prince Andrew so uh
Vinnie what new story do we have on this
and what should people be expecting
coming up this week well I I tweeted
this last Night P regard this is what is
the scariest thing about this whole
situation if today they release
something with proof that Bill Clinton
had sex with an underage girl guess what
would happened to him Pat absolutely
nothing and that's a that's a sad fact
he's Untouchable his wife is Untouchable
Bill Gates is untouchable nobody caness
with these people but and I want you
guys to know this there was these are in
older emails a high-ranking JP Morgan
executive s an email cracking a joke
about Epstein showing up to a concert
when with Miley Cyrus when she was 15
years old this is Chase these are the
top brass at at Chase but they were
saying um they allegedly opened private
banking accounts and credit card
accounts for 18-year-olds said to be
Epstein's inner Entourage joking he was
their sugar daddy and JP Morgan knew he
was a pedophile all these people know
they work with him and that's why they
just they had to pay recently this in
2023 $290 million like hush money to all
these victims but uh I I just think uh
even if it comes out Pat nothing's going
to happen to him and that's that's the
sad scary thing is that he is
Untouchable nothing is going to happen
to him Tom you have any thoughts on this
well the list of names doesn't seem um
like it's told us anything new we knew
Randy Andy was there um Randy Andy
that's what they call no that's what the
tabloids call Andrew yeah that's the
headline over there Daily Mail Randy
Andy and uh his mom was upset um uh God
rester Soul before the queen passed away
so we've kind of seen all this come and
go and it doesn't seen anything new the
number of trips you know 50 times you
know I maybe Clinton can say it's 25 cuz
that was run trips um or something but I
don't see anything new here I don't see
any like brand new names but but guys
question why are they read acting the
the the criminals in this like okay I
hide the people I don't want any of the
women or underage boys I don't know all
these names obviously keep those people
I don't want them public every male that
went there especially after he was
convicted of pedophilia I want to see
their names who why are we protecting
these people I don't understand well
they're going to release it so if you go
to the story Rob go to the story on
Newsweek which I think they're probably
doing the best job on this I'll send it
to you uh the title of it is Jeff if you
type in I just send it to you Jeffrey
Epstein's list of Associates uh uh type
in Jeffrey Epstein's list of right there
number three number three uh list there
okay they go up keep going up obviously
they're going to put Trump on the front
page keep going up yeah of course they
going even though he didn't go to the
island keep going up keep going up keep
going up keep going up so is this the
one yeah right there right that demon he
look a demon so who is the associate
list okay what what's the date on this
Rob see if this is one one December 20th
no no I have a one one I just sent you
so if you go to this one so so it's
interesting by the way very go up on
this story look what the title was on
this one look what they put on the title
on this one look what we just
accidentally found Jeffrey Epstein's
list of Associates Sparks oh no
conspiracy theory this is just 12 days
ago okay now watch the one that just
came out yesterday Rob put the one that
I just sent you yesterday what happened
news week why are you changing the title
now it's no longer a conspiracy
list of Associates what we know as names
to be revealed so go again they use the
same exact picture okay go a little
lower what is happening so let's look at
the questions Rob let's see what
questions they got so will there be any
new allegations yes the okay so that
that's the new thing unsealed at Tom
saying there's nothing new there will be
new this upcoming uh batch of court
documents will include names of
additional Epstein associate alleged
perpetrators and Co conspir okay that's
good why are they being released now
because a Loretta presca the judge held
in December there was no legal
justification for continuing to keep
Anonymous 150 wow okay so she's like we
got to release it fine go to the next
question next question is what where are
the documents coming from they're coming
from a a lawsuit filed by Virginia
Jeffrey which we just talked about an
alleged trafficking victim against
Epstein's jailed former girlfriend
jaline Maxwell she has alleged that
Maxwell arranged for her to have sex
with Epstein with other prominent man
including okay keep going
lower are the names of Epstein's
Associates already known there has been
extensive litigation in the Epstein case
and many names have already been known
they include those accused of wrongdoing
but also people who work for Epstein
flew on his plane or visited his home
some were mentioned okay are there any
names of particular interest yes the
court will the court records will
contain details of Jane Doe
162 okay so we know that one keep going
lore uh is Bill Clinton likely to be
comp implicated in the wrongdoing no she
made no allegations of wrongdoing by
Clinton and there is no indication the
sealed records contain any wrongdoing on
his part okay could this be embarrassing
for Clinton yes because she met Clinton
in little St James Epstein's Private
Island Maxwell had claimed in court that
Clinton had never been there whoops okay
Theo was a mistake which version is
correct flight locks so look I mean this
is a real deal that's coming out okay
this is a real deal that's coming out
for whatever reason a bunch of different
uh people were writing yesterday that
this person SC by the way some of the
names like Spielberg's on this list
there's some very interesting names on
oh yeah I mean to Tom every dude
everybody went there and the problem is
it was post pedophilia uh prostitution
conviction and Bill Gates P I don't know
if people people have to like really
look at these old videos I sent rob a
video P when they interviewed I forgot
the woman's name She interviewed Melinda
Gates and if you see towards the end of
this one minute clip she goes I saw him
I met him I felt evil personified like
that's the reason she left him Bill
Gates listen don't be fooled by this
whole I'm I talk like Kel the Frog and
here's vaccines and he's a humanitarian
I can I show this look listen how
disgusting she's look at she had
nightmares about meeting him go ahead
you know it was also widely reported
that Bill had a a friendship or business
or some kind of contact with Jeffrey
Epstein and that you were not uh that
that was very upsetting to you did that
play a role in the in the divorce at all
in this process yeah as I said it's not
one thing it was many things but I did
not like uh that he'd had meetings with
Jeffrey
Epstein and you made that clear to him I
made that clear to him I also met
Jeffrey Epstein exactly one time did you
yes because I wanted to see who this man
was and um I regretted it from the
second I stepped in the door he was
abhorent he was evil personified I had
nightmares about it afterwards so you
know my heart breaks for these young
women cuz that's how I felt and here I'm
an older woman my God I feel terrible
for those young women was awful you felt
that the moment you walked I didn't
realize yeah and you shared that with
Bill and he still continued to spend
time with him any of the questions
remaining about what Bill's relationship
there was those are for Bill to
answer
evil dude think about this this she she
has a head on her shoulders she met him
one time and she knew like by the way
let me tell you what happened yesterday
the kids we were watching a movie Tetris
Tom have you seen this Tetris movie that
just came out not yet okay you have I
thought about you you got to watch it
it's a Tetris movie that came out on
Apple and actually did a really good job
of how the history of it the Russia
being involved the mob being involved
documentary you know who was involved in
the deal with Tetris you know who Robert
Maxwell you know who Robert Maxwell was
Robert Maxwell was J Maxwell's father
you know how the movie ends at the end
with Robert Maxwell Robert Maxwell
didn't have a million dollar to pay
Russia to win the rights to Tetris
licensing cuz he was going bankrupt he
ended up stealing $900 million of
Pension funds from his people from other
people ended up doing a $5 billion
whatever lawsuit he go he dies Goes to
Jail his son who's in it as well same
thing he has issues backing him up and
then his daughter I mean the genetics
comes from from a lineage of people that
are doing some shady stuff here so I I
don't know uh uh I know a lot of people
who are linked to this I I'm not I don't
know a lot of people that are linked to
this I know a lot of the people who are
linked to this are probably sitting here
this week talking to a bunch of lawyers
because who else can you kill that's say
did you find that clip Rob about the uh
can you play that clip check this out
guy goes in asking for basic report on
Epstein of the day check who is this
this his brother right this is his
brother watch thisan lower man lower man
okay but as of right now you're telling
me you can't find the PCR report not for
the 10th of August 2019 ma Max not in
it's not in Department database I don't
know why if it's supposed to be there
we'll find out but first you got to get
the letters of administration before you
can take them anywhere yeah you see
because the date on here is the the 10th
of 19 that's the day they found them
they took him he was
dead well then they might have taken him
directly to the mor no was in the
hospital I have photographs of him in
the hospital too oh well I'm you didn't
tell me that I'm just going by yeah no
no I understand I'm just trying to
explain what I know yeah well I don't
know what happened but uh so far he's
not in the fire department database
weird I don't know why mhm um too many
too many listen man the look is it still
going and uh could they have taken him
somewhere was she he he has a photograph
of the fire department personnel that
doesn't that do generates documentation
that's just a photograph what did he say
I couldn't hear he said that because you
see the fire department because you see
the fire department personnel there that
doesn't mean they provided documentation
it could they told me they did I spoke
to
them yeah and they were the ones who
suggested I get the PCR
reports well well they're saying one
thing but the computer is saying
something else you can pause it right
there go ahead Adam there is no telling
how high up this goes and how deep this
goes and what tentacles this will lead
to there's no telling there's a lot of
very rich powerful access driven people
who are basically behind closed doors
doing everything they can to make sure
the truth never comes out okay did
epsteen King kill himself well we all
want to know here's what we do know this
story is not going away as much as the
rich and the powerful and the accessible
want this gone okay there's a yearning
and a clamoring in American people and
the people worldwide they're like not so
fast buddy that ain't happening in my
watch but always always I'm glad you
brought up the Rob Robert Maxwell Tetris
thing FTM follow the money they always
say access is power now just because you
went on Epstein's plane doesn't make you
guilty because we all know that one of
the major things he was pedaling not
even money not even access was blackmail
was extortion was Hush money we know
that so RFK went on his plane he
admitted it twice with his kid with his
family okay cool nothing wrong with that
but we also know that Les Wexler owner
of Victoria Secrets who Whitney Webb has
done an amazing job she's been on the
podcast with us a few times basically
saying what's going on here okay Leon
black owner of Apollo Management right
multi- multi-billion dollar asset
manager paid him a half a billion
dollars in consult consult what's going
on with that so we all know that access
is power so just if we understand the
basic template is Hey listen this guy's
got money follow the money access his
power cool we're going to get on this
plane we're going to do meetings just
because you going to somebody's meeting
go to a going on on an island doesn't
make you guilty now do I think Bill
Clinton was on that island probably
banging some chicks instead of Hillary
yes does that mean that they were under
18 we don't know but the reality is this
and this is the bottom line the story is
not going away the people want answer
the I okay I agree that the story is not
going away but I'm telling you right now
when it's that high patent it's that
that powerful evil cuz that's what it
comes down to you know you know Vinnie
people thought the mob was never going
to come down people in you were in New
York people thought the mob was never
ever the the what was a movie called The
untouchable right everything was the
untouchable you can never touch these
guys they have them in their pocket they
have the judge in their pocket they have
the cops in their pocket eventually
someone's going to say bro I'm not doing
it you know what the story was about
Tetris one of the guys that worked for
gorbachov yesterday when I'm watching
the movie one of the guys in the movie
that was working for gorbachov was
negotiating a side deal with Robert
Maxwell to get a check from him and he
kept wanting to take the deal away from
the other honest guy So eventually the
girl that's chasing saying why do you
want this deal to be with Maxwell and
he's like what are you doing isn't it
Russia first isn't Homeland country
first and then eventually he publicly
gets caught the fact that he was getting
money from Maxwell directly in a
communistic nation she finds out she
tells gorbach of Boom he goes down moral
the story is when you try to pay off so
many people eventually one person's
going to be like I didn't get my money
what are you going to do now so and when
there kids involved when there's kids
involved I don't know you may be right
you may not be right but the fact that
judges would you have thought a year ago
that judges are going to come and say no
I want know the list would you have
thought that I I wouldn't have thought
that but when I like and I I understand
the mafia part cuz you know Mafia but
Pat when it's when it's presidential
when it's Banks when it's the those guys
protect like dude brother these people
are more powerful than the mafia saying
that's what I'm saying but but you know
taking you guys are on the same page
yeah 100% so all and at the end just to
close it at the only thing that gives me
happiness in here is that God we we
might not hold them our courts might not
hold them accountable God at the end of
the day will hold their feet to the fire
trust me that's that's the only way it
makes me feel good I'm looking forward
to the rest of the names and the dates
so that people like our friend great
journalist can now run down the trails
paint the picture put it all together
like a puzzle but right now it's like
we're getting this big tease hey there's
more names there's more names you're
going to unseal them and they're like
prince Andrew wait we know that name and
that's why I say there was to me to my
ears there was nothing new yet bill
Clinton okay now it's 50 times okay well
we kind of knew he was there more than
once all of that is there I want to see
the rest of the names and I want to see
some journalists paint the pictures and
run down just like Whitney Webb has done
because now you've got something to work
with and to go chase and I'm to it get
Whitney Webb on standby buddy all right
let's go to the next story so that one
is the first story so before we get into
the next story we got a bunch of them
here let's go to our sponsors first
American Harford gold so look I've been
in the financial industry since 9/11 the
day before 911 and I've owned stocks
bonds mutual funds real estate crypto
gold you name it I've owned it but the
one thing that's very important part of
my portfolio all these years is gold I
love having a percentage of my network
in Gold that I have access to in case of
many different things that's why we
chose to work with our new sponsor
American Hartford gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American Harford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American Harford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call 866939 6984 again
6984 okay next story LA office building
sells for $13.5 million $15 million less
than its sale price a decade ago this is
a market watch
story um page nine page nine here we go
la Aon Center a 62 story office building
Rob can you pull up the picture to see
what it looks like was sold for $153
million marking the largest fourth
quarter deal for office space in the
Western United States as reported by
Newark Group Inc the buyer Carol Wood
LPA La based private equity for acquired
the building located in downtown LA's
Financial District the property was 64%
lease at the time of sale with diverse
tenants including Aon and Morrison and
for uh Forester uh the sale price
represents a significant drop from his
2014 purchase price of 268 million
unfreaking believe Vinnie from 268
million to $153 million uh the pandemic
induced challenges in the in office
occupancy contributed to this decrease
with the US office occupancy rate
ranging from 40% to 65% Springer 2023
Tom you hear the story how much of this
is California how much of this is real
estate how much of this is interest
rates how much of this is just working
from home uh this is California number
one this is 70 I'm so I'm going to say
this this is 70% California you want to
know why if that building was in the
middle of Miami Adam downtown Miami
right now it would be 80% leased in in
90 days because there's so many uh
businesses have come to South Florida
there's plenty of demand so why is it
selling like this in California there's
not demand why is there not demand it's
California policies taxation you know uh
downtown crime homelessness all around
downtown where do you go if you work in
that building where do you go for lunch
you got to see it downtown folks it's
really bad so I see 70% California and
probably 25% interest rates that's kind
of ding it but look who's buying it as
we predicted a private Equity Firm
swooping in buying undervalued assets
ladies and gentlemen that's their
business and they're and they're
conducting their business very well
right now but that's my take yeah Dana
White said it best Miami's the new La so
you saw what he said when he was talking
I think to the elk boy so shout out to
you Dana White by the way Miami is
pretty packed guys we're good we don't
need anyone else prices already up but
Miami is the new La Rob show thect um La
used to be where all the cool kids hung
out now it's all Miami La used to be the
scene now it's all Miami sorry it is
what it is um but the reality is this
what we've learned since covid is that
residential real estate has skyrocketed
as far as supply and demand and
Commercial Real Estate is plummeted and
whether you call it WFA or wfh work from
home or work from anywhere a lot of
companies simply don't need all that
space and some deals private Equity
firms whether it's even Black Rock
that's buying up a lot of uh residential
stuff and we talked about Blackstone
whatever's going on with that the
mortgage stuff with Brandon uh they just
don't need all that space and people are
just working from home and whether it's
California and all the ridiculous laws
and red tape that they put up there and
people leaving and Gavin Newsome being
the U-Haul employee of the year multiple
times over it is what it is at this
point in California so P you if you if
you bought something like that if like
you you have a now you got basically for
half off right it was half off give or
give or take give or take how long do
you think somebody could just buy that
and sit on it will it go back up in
price only if you're able to take that
from 60% to 90% 85% the key to selling a
property like you know we're looking at
properties right now the proper one
property we're looking at is smaller but
it's leased at 80% it's 50% more than
another property that's bigger but it's
100% vacant people are not buying the
property for you know just how big and
massive and beautiful the property is
they want to know who's leasing it who's
already in there in how many years so
the way they'll look at it is they'll
look at the list and they'll say we have
22 tenants these guys got 19,000 Square
ft and their least expires 2029 these
guys have such and such their at lease
expires 2032 oh wow it's a 10-e lease
yeah these guy and then you're like ah
okay average about seven and a half
years got it okay here's the offer they
do the math here's the offer for the
property it's simple as what it is so if
a company like that is buying it they
know they're going to fill this place up
and they're going to make their money
they're not worried about whether
they're going to to lose money or not
the average person that buys it it's
going to be a different story these guys
are
mathematicians it everything they buy
it's purely logical not emotional very
rarely emotional if it's emotional it's
because it's a very well-known building
this is not an emotional building this
is just a big ass building all right
let's go to the next story what's the
story with Tucker and Ben Shapiro
Fighting by the way Tucker Carlson
launches launches stunning attack on Ben
Shapiro he obviously doesn't care about
America uh is what Tucker
says he accused Shapiro of not caring
about the United States particularly due
to Shapiro's focus on the Israel Gaza
conflict stating I can't imagine how
someone like that could get an audience
of people who claim to care about
America because he doesn't obviously
Carlson expressed frustration with the
right-wing's intense focus on foreign
conflicts such as Ukraine and Israel
while neglecting pressing uh domestic
issues like the nation's Financial
stability and immigration concerns he
questioned why they weren't addressing
these vital matters saying they have
said said nothing about that and they're
focused with laser intensity on foreign
conflicts they don't care about this
country at all would you have ever
thought that a Tucker Carlson's going to
call Ben Shapiro out and say you don't
care about the country at all what your
thought well for me I'm looking at this
actually I think they both have their um
uh right sides of the argument but this
is beyond politics this is beyond uh
anything this is personal for they've
been feuding on this uh topic for months
now and we all know that Ben Shapiro uh
as smart as he is obviously is an
American Jewish Man Tucker Carlson is an
American Christian man Ben has vested
interest with what's going on in Israel
he's an Israel advocate so I totally
understand both sides of the argument
like you're an Armenian American right
if there was something going on in
Armenia you would have some things to
say about it if there was something
going on in Assyria there's no Assyria
but exactly you'd have some people going
on language a little bit in Modesto if
something was happen
something was going on in you know
whatever
Scandinavia Tom would have something to
say about it so you you know America is
made up of a coalition of people from
other countries that's what make America
so great is that we've taken in
immigrants a little too much these days
a little from all over the world that
have their backgrounds I like what Dana
White also had to say is like you're not
Italian-American you're just freaking
American you're not African-American
you're just freaking American you're not
Mexican-American you're just American so
we have to get back to the sense of
roots and purpose in America America
first I I do understand that but at the
same time we have something called
domestic policy and foreign policy we
have something called multilateralism
and called unilateralism we need to
stand by our allies whether it's the EU
whether it's Australia whether it's
Canada whether it's Israel whether you
can some kind of say Ukraine I don't
know about that but that that we need to
have our allies back and our allies need
to know what do you think about I
understand what you just stated the
facts I get the facts what's so how do
you process it's personal you think this
is personal okay so what do you think
about it what do you think about I I I
to just say he doesn't care about
America I don't think that's the case I
think and obviously Adam nailed that he
is Jewish and it's just for months it
was for the first month and a half all
it was was Israel this bomb them wipe
them out didn't care about the civilian
didn't care about then he just wiped
them out so I could see how Tucker would
get upset but I I do see Tucker's point
and the fact that P it's like
everybody's looking outward outward
outward and you said this I think uh two
months ago when you're like one year
shut everything down I'm sorry everybody
take a time out we're going to turn
around and look at America and not help
everybody and give away and and and I
think that's the that's the way to do it
hiring free recruiting free one year
were taking no immigrants no immigrat no
nothing not even Ukraine sorry guys deal
with it deal with the war that you've
been losing from the beginning Tom both
of these guys are media experts and
Tucker knows exactly what he's doing
obviously you don't care about America
one millisecond later a synaps in Tucker
Carlson's head is telling him that
that's going to be the click head
headline that that's going to get people
into you think you think that's what you
think in his mind he's trying to get a
short clip out no no his mind he's
trying to get his point out and he
understands how to get people doing that
yeah because I H I have a lot of respect
for Tucker Carlson both as a newsman and
as an American and as an entrepreneur
and I think he knows exactly what he's
doing what he is pointing out is saying
that domestic policy is so important
right now look what's happening to our
cities look what's happening to our
economy look what the interest rates
affordable housing education America
make a list and Tucker is saying
domestic policy is so important right
now and you guys are preoccupied with
all these foreign conflicts Shapiro on
the other side is saying look what's
happening to Israel because he's got a
very strong Pro Zionist Israel flag that
he waves I think I think it's as simple
as that and Tucker knows how to get the
dialogue spun up and saying obviously
you don't care about America that gets
people talking about it and Tucker's
point I think is stronger than Ben's
point it's not to say that there's no
point in in Israel uh you know Hamas and
the Palestinian conflict that's going on
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
that the domestic point that Tucker is
making is pretty freaking powerful and
he's asking people look at all the
issues we got to deal with in here and I
I bet he would agree with you 100% you
know let's have a moratorium on uh
immigration and then get it done right
and do the following things to deal with
domestic issues yeah can you imagine if
a president gets elected and says okay
guys you elected me here's what we're
doing one year we're not taking any
immigrants period one year we're not
giving any money away to anybody else
when it comes on to war one year the
world's got to figure out their problems
for one year and let's see if everybody
else can handle it or not a year later
we'll go ahead and address other
people's problems and here's how you do
it you make a list of problems you're
having in America just so you know where
you live where your kids go to to school
where your family lives where you spend
time working where your job is where
your company is where you spend most of
your life is here these are the proms we
got boom boom boom boom boom boom let's
address these I think we're going to
need about a year to address this then
we can look at other people's problems I
think that's a very logical uh approach
of taking it to solving issues um do do
I think it's like the two heavy weights
of the conservative side going at it as
well and there's an element to it that's
entertaining and they both maybe even
want it maybe I don't know um you know
obviously you saw what happened with the
uh Pierce Morgan when the whole Israel
and Gaza debates all the comedians he
was putting them up 18 million 20
million 12 million 6 million but this is
working keep doing it keep doing it keep
doing it but there's also another part
of it that's about guys you know this
has been a chaotic run we've had since
2016 let's see if we can lower the
temperature by 2025 mathematically
impossible to lower the temperature 2024
impossible to lower the temperature in
2024 but in 2025 there's something we
can do to lower the temperature and in
2020 2025 in 2024 the best part if we
can pull this off it's going to be very
hard to do unifying
people in
2024 would be by far the most important
thing to do if these guys can't get
around the same table them others from
the conservative side can you imagine a
symposium think about the Symposium you
ready Tucker Ben musk Rogan put Trump
put a bunch of these guys okay at a RFK
at one event oh my God what do you think
would happen with that you don't have an
arena big enough to want to fill how
many people are going to want to be
there and you know what they talk about
let me tell you what we're talking about
here I'm a humanist my name Isam husk
yes I'm trying to build a you know
civilization or what do you call it a
colony in on uh Mars Mars whatever but
at the same time I love America I love
this country hey I'm such and such but I
love America hey I'm a Jew but I love
America hey I'm a this but I love
America think about what kind of a
message that would send to the world if
some of the sharpest brightest people
unified around America as an idea what
that would do to the world we got to
figure out we need unifiers and
synergist in 2024 we we've had so we've
had such a run of dividers back to back
to back back to back to back we need a
new run of synergist and unifiers sit
down talk you want to argue great just
the other day Rob did you see the Seth
McFarland debate with Bill Mah on the
vaccine did you see that yeah what' you
think about it I I I loved it because
well two things a I got to see like I I
I I've I've been around Seth M McFarland
at at a nightclub he drinking Jack
Daniels really really really cool guy
really really generous but to see that
you know they're both obviously liberals
for him to to to have that point of view
and for them to actually Pat have the
conversation and it not become no no
you're wrong you're wrong and then the
conversation stop at least I got to how
long how long is the longest one Rob can
you see what do you have right there 641
what's the one above it they're all 641
for this 30 second clip play the 30
second one see what it is let's see what
the 30 second one is uh go ahead play
this clip here and but tell me what we
disagree on when you do real time and
we'll try to make that that the topic
because I'd love to U as I I think I
mean look I I think we disagree on the
fact that I think that the public health
infrastructure despite being absolutely
inadequate prior to co did as good a job
as they could have done no during Co and
it pisses me the off when I see
people on them when I see I see it
must because you like like steered it
all the way back to that again like tell
me what weag on pretty wild to say that
good job during Co even though it was
inadequate preo do you think he's
getting P does he have to say that you
think or he genuinely in his heart feels
that cuz this is Seth McFarland this guy
he is this is a professional actor he's
in that Community he is he's in that
space what do you think Tom you look you
had to look like I not not I'm not say
why don't you do this but Rob why don't
you go play the six-minute clip but just
don't play the whole six minutes and
just play the first like minut go and
play this clip and maybe fast forb a
little bit go ahead
but then why are doctors wrong about so
much about a lot too and yes and but
very often people who aren't doctors
have been writer about things um like
like like what would be an example of
that I would think uh this country did
not allow for um uh natural immunity to
be considered and I know this is a
subject dear to your heart even if you
had the disease you still had to get a
vaccine that's powerful stupid they
don't do that in Europe I think they do
that here there's mandatory vaccination
in grade in schools right but if you
already but if you already had the
disease you have natural immunity we
didn't seem we didn't seem to believe in
that that was debunked though I mean
that wasun don't you know people have
had Co four or five times I do that's
not natural immunity there's no immunity
there you've had Co five times watch
what he says probably because you had
too many vaccines I didn't have Co the
vaccine gave you co uh well that's
certainly nothing unscientific about the
fact that the vaccine
which does weaken you in order to
strengthen you says do all vaccines
exactly yeah but while you're in a
weakened State yes that's why so many
people like me got it did not have it I
I thought it was a great exchange but
but the point is here's a point okay
Vinnie two years ago that conversation's
not being had absolutely I'm telling you
right now two three years ago that
conversation is not me that would have
Tak down the internet but but the fact
that this conversation is being had GR
ually we are being forced to go this way
you know why here's how this works think
about the longest time you held a grudge
with somebody how long was it okay I
don't we're not giving names I'm just
saying might still be going okay but but
think think about the longest and by the
way let me kind of bring you close I'm
talking family I'm talking blood I'm not
talking like a friend a friend okay I'm
talk maybe even best friend what is the
longest grudge you ever had like years
give me a timeline 10 years go honestly
Rob two years and it was my best friend
from Seventh GR up until 3 or 4 years
ago where we started arguing about the
covid vaccine I didn't take it my my
employer mandated it I said no I lost my
job you're employer Val Tim and made you
take not this employer freaking let me
talk to these guys my previous employer
I worked in radio they they mandated it
I said no my best friend worked for Live
Nation at the time he took it we had
several arguments I tried to explain to
him why I didn't think it was necessary
for me to take it we didn't talk for 2
and a half years until he finally came
back and said hey I'm sorry about that
you were right and I was wrong best
friend can he said that to you yes and
again best friend for 20 years holy
you guys better now yeah best friends
again shout out to your best friend for
acknowledging should have been better
what's the longest you've gone with a
grudge family or a best friend not
friend couple years okay what's yours
Tom it's probably family about 5 years
uh
Vinnie Vinnie still holding on but when
it comes to friends and stuff and this
past 2023 I called the two people that I
was not even talking to and I initiated
that hey whatever it was I'm sorry I
forgot about it one never got back to me
the other one just two days ago hit me
up now let's categorize grudges okay
let's categorize grudges one Grudge is
what hardcore betrayal that's permanent
forever set that aside right let's set
that aside we're not we're not going to
talk about well why don't you go and
apologize to no bro that's betrayal okay
that is gone all right let's put the
other Grudge as what you're offended
cool all right let's put that over here
let's put the one in Middle
disrespected and did something that was
a real stupid thing that one or the
other person did and they apologize
right how long can we go with a grudge
two years two and a half years three I
don't know it ain't 50 years okay so
what's the point here dude America's so
sick and tired of holding grudges
against the other side they want to sit
down and say dude I don't hate you as
much as you think I do yeah you and I
had different things with vaccine why do
we let the mainstream media make me
think you're a horrible person why do we
think the mainstream media make me think
that you're an idiot for not taking a
vaccine you know what bro I effed up
yeah I Eed up too all right cool you
want to have a drink here let's smoke a
joint and that's what Bill Mah is doing
here right I don't know if America can
go for too long holding a grudge I don't
think it's a natural thing that we have
in our bodies some of us again what's
betrayal you can't like you know a snake
uh I saw something the other day a snake
betrays you and then they shed and then
they may look a little bit better but
they're still a snake they're still
going to betray you if you keep you know
forgiving a snake in your life you're
the okay that guy's DNA is to
betray you consistently over and over
and over again but for everybody else
you know in this community that guy's a
Democrat so guess where Seth lives in he
lives in Hollywood what does Hollywood
look like a Hollywood is him they're
invited to the same parties they're on
the Tablo they're on all the magazin
they're being talked about you're in
that space the managers the ca the WME
the all that stuff he is in that
Community what do you expect him what do
you think the people around him believe
the same exact thing he believes in what
is Bill he's sitting there
debating conversations challenging all
this other stuff the fact that we're
having these conversations as crazy as
this sounds we are getting closer to
each other this doesn't mean we're going
to be 100% over it it just means we're
making progress this is a very good good
sign when you see these two guys talking
to one another we going to say I know I
agree but but when it comes to the like
the powers that be though the one that
he's talking about that's the the
science the fouches the president saying
it's a winter of death it's a war and
unvaccinated that's a grudge B but
that's not your friend though remember I
said family or friend that's not a
friend that is a divider I have a list
of people whom I watched how well they
divide oh my God I got a list of I can
you know
who's one of the top ones I'm talking in
my personal life and business there's a
few guys and I I studied their playbook
I'm like wow you are so good and I
called him out one time and I said to
his face I said hey you know this is
what you do you know that right you
do watch you to divide
people said you do he like you know no
no you think so no man I've seen you do
it to this guy to that guy to this guy
to that guy to You're So Proud what you
you're so good at what you do so with
that guy that's not a friend that's not
a a grudge that's a dark human being
that I'm not trying to be friend I'm
talking about somebody you love care
friend got it family care about that now
you're saying I hate you how the hell do
we get here what happened did you truly
betray me maybe you did okay then you're
in this category don't worry about it we
don't need a friendship ever again in
America yesterday the the Tio and Dylan
are saying so Dad what do you think
about our country being called essay I
said what he said yeah America's essay I
said what the hell is that what I'm like
okay here we go another FNAF book you
read Five Nights at Freddy's that I have
to sit here and learn about another
character say no we're we're we're
sa what the hell is that I'm like what
the guys up says no we're the States of
America we're no longer
United oh wow that might have been me
Pat might have said that yeah t and
Dylan they're like we're no longer USA
we're the sa Were the States of America
wherever they picked it up maybe they
bad influence of but but it's not bad
influence it was it was true freaking
Vinnie's already dividing my America I'm
holding a grudge right now I'm telling
it publicly me and Vin have a grudge
officially today oh no all right let's
go to the next one large number of
Americans want a strong rough
anti-democratic leader what are they
talking about so this is a story from
the conversation researched by Ali Haney
College Center for political
participation revealed that
approximately onethird of 1500 cor
respondents expressed a willingness to
support leaders who would take
uncompromising decisive action even if
it meant violating Democratic norms for
example responders were asked if they
believe that the only way our country
can solve its current problems is by
supporting tough leaders who will crack
down on these who undermine American
values about a third of the respons
respondents agreed or strongly agreed
with such ideas approximately 90% of
Republicans would support tough leaders
who crack down on groups perceived as
undermining American values while H over
half of Democrats held similar views
almost half of strongest Republican
party supporters and over a third of
strong Democratic party supporters
endorse the idea that it is acceptable
to bend the rules for political goals
interesting to bend the rules for
political and this the chart by the way
if you're looking at it so if you look
at the strongly agree strongly disagree
statement the only way our country can
solve the current problems is by
supporting tough leaders who will crack
down on those who undermine the American
values strong Democrats you see uh what
they're saying green strongly agree okay
interesting uh uh not strong Democrats a
little bit lean Democrat okay not that
much Independence 19% lean rep
Republican 27 not strong Republicans 26
strong Republicans are like no bro hold
these Moses accountable I want them
going to jail is what I want them to be
right so what do you think about this
Tom when you're hearing a story about
the fact that American people maybe is
this caused by a Joe Biden presidency of
two years where they're like dude have
some kind of a backbone the freaking
Middle East attacked us 78 times in a
few weeks in a month of December you
don't do and now we have to sit
here and bend our back and apolog maybe
we should do something about it Tom your
thoughts yeah this has been below the
surface for a while and now it's showing
up what what it says is that people all
around the World especially Americans
right now crave a strong leader speaking
with Clarity who will do something
strong leader speaking with Clarity will
do something you can look back in
history and see how did let's forget
about ma let's forget about Stalin
forget about uh Hitler let's look at
musolini as a case study Pat musolini
told people he would make the trains run
on time and he would help Rectify what
was going on in the Italian economy and
he got democratically elected now he
turned out to be a a bad guy but the
point is when you see elections like
that when people have had enough they
are craving that strong leader speaking
with Clarity and Authority who's going
to get something done and it's doesn't
surprise and right now damn straight the
Joe Biden presidency he's been sort of a
last straw of wishy-washy Washington now
Americans are are starting to speak like
this you went over the strongly agree
look at the agree if you add the 22
strong agree and the 37 agree 90% that's
59% of Democrats said you know what I'm
in that's the line that I look at the
strong Democrats 59% who said strongly
agree and agree you know what I'm in
exactly and I was just going to say
that's that's the where I'm going with
this we all know that especially if
you're on the Republican side of the
aisle you look at strong as an
authoritarian of type of leader you know
some somebody will say authoritarian
some people will say strong but he's
definitely authoritative meaning like he
ain't messing around so we we already
understand that what is it almost 90% of
Republicans wanton a strong leader we
get that but the Democrats the Democrats
you when you look at someone like an
Obama no nobody called him strong you
might have said you might have said that
he was Charming or well spoken or
empathetic but he wasn't a strong leader
and the Democrats are even looking at
Joe Biden frail old scile some may say
Vinnie's already diagnosed him with
dementia based on his medical reputation
but what we can what we can all agree
upon is that he's sort of feckless and
ineffective and definitely not strong so
when you see Democrats out there being
like give me a badass mofo out there
that is a Telltale sign that America's
yearning something a little bit more you
mean like what what we had with Trump
when shaking everybody's hand and
ripping their arms off slapping Putin
hitting Kim jung-un on the shoulder you
mean that strong the guy that didn't
care the guy that was just talking
that was actually an alpha weird what
didn't we have that now you guys want it
back exactly Obama what was his one word
change change yes we can no no no no the
first first postage stamp think Obama
hope and what is the first word out of
Trump's mouth make make wow good point
make America great again what was Joe
Biden's slogan uh sleep who are
we is it nap time again no I'm serious
hope versus make America great yet hope
make but we had we listen Adam going
back to that point we had strong and
listen besides the feelings everything
was kind of good until covid and now
look now look would you would you guys
say I want to know from all three of you
is Joe Biden going to go down as one of
the worst Presidents that we've had in
this past four years be honest with
yourself what do you is that is that
like trick question no no no no I'm
being genuine from everything that's
happened from the day he got in to right
now are you choking or you serious I'm
dead of course he's going to go down as
one of the worst presid who who would
you who would you put the question you
don't need to ask me though you need to
ask Democrats they need to do that poll
because his his approval rating right
now is 39% do you know there's never
been a president that's won at 30 30 in
the 30 percentile nobody ever ever
they're all one one one timers okay
they're all one-timers and by the way
Trump is in that group as well okay but
there's never been a person that's one
at 30% he's at 39.3% right now 55.4 is
this approval rating I'll just add one
more thing we always go back to that
Wall Street Journal article where they
said that decline in American values
right Family Values uh community service
religion everything that's sort of been
declining in America there's definitely
something permeating in America under
the service that's been basically been
exposed where every just sort of normal
semblance of any human being in America
proud of proud Americans are looking
around they're like what's going on
around here these days we're so focused
on identity politics and gender and
chicks that have that we forgot about
that exactly what's the major issues in
this America not culture wars that is
that that affecting America actual Wars
what's going on in Ukraine what's going
on in Israel what's going around the
world North Korea over there Taiwan
potentially happening what's going on
with the debt what's going on Americans
the the fastest growing religion in
America is no religion whatsoever less
people are having kids there's so much
going on in America you know we always
that cycle of uh weak men create strong
times strong times we all know this
thing but there's something happening in
America where even Democrats you know
the loving empathetic they're like yeah
now we're not playing that game the bill
Mars of the world are arguing with the
south mcmarlin of the world and they're
basically drawing a line of the sand
like yeah this ain't exactly classic
liberalism this is a Democratic party
I'm not used to so there's something
happening right here we just need to be
careful that there's not actually an
authoritarian in office but you know the
media will do a good job which why
example of melini yeah and and by the
way check this out so a lot of talk
right now is being being brought up
about Nikki Haley as the VP okay so
Nikki Haley as Trump's VP she doesn't
reject the idea says uh they work well
together Nikki Haley when asked uh about
the possibility of becoming Trump's
running mate in the 2024 election
responded president Trump and I worked
very well together why because I told
him the truth while she didn't
categorically reject the idea she
emphasized her intention to win the
Republican Nom nomination for president
stating I've never played for second I'm
going to I'm not going to start now
despite the openness to the idea of a
trump haly ticket there's opposition
within Trump Circle his son Donald Trump
Jr expressed reluctance calling Haley a
puppet of the establishment in
Washington DC and a favorite of the
billionaire class Trump himself
previously referred to Haley as bird
brain in a post on Truth social Tom
thoughts on uh Nikki Haley as a VP do
you think that's likely to happen no I
don't think it's likely to happen and
here's the strategy I bet I went back
it's funny you say this this
um I went back and I was looking at
Nikki Haley's quotes and I was looking
at her you kind of a campaign position
statements and stuff and at the
beginning of her campaign when she was
trying to legitimize her ability to stay
on stage she was really critical of
trump I believe that her Camp if you
look at what they were reading they
thought he was dead they thought he's
not going to be in a ballot too many of
these court cases and remember we've
crossed the lump it's like he's still
here well now never never mind brag in
New York now we have Georgia he's still
here uh nothing's been convicted yet
he's still here and now we've got State
Supreme Courts and what's going on he's
still here I think she thought he'd be
gone and she was negative on him and she
now I believe is positioning for VP now
that she's got enough leverage in terms
of where she is in the polls I think
she's trying to position for a spot and
I think the people and the money around
her want her to be that VP and they want
her to be the dick chenian heels to do
it exactly what Dick Cheney did with
bush you know I think that's I think
that's the positioning and I think
that's the play and I think that's
what's showing up right now you know who
she reminds me of Tom let me tell who
she reminds me of she reminds me of uh
of I'll text you the name you know who
she is she reminds me of somebody in the
insurance space snobby know it all
entitled degree been around the block I
haven't texted it to you yet I will in a
minute uh snobby entitled do I have your
attention Tom or are you yeah only only
come on Tom get off the only fans be
here with us so to me for she she gives
me that Vibe you know why she gives me
that Vibe and I may be wrong I'm so glad
being wrong with this I'm totally okay
with that because she has presence on
stage she's very confident if
nowadays you as a presidential candidate
don't go on podcast I see you as snobby
if nowadays you as a presidential
candidate don't go sit down with other
podcast and talk and open up for an hour
or two do long form I see you as you're
hiding something guess what she hasn't
done type in the word Nikki Haley and
podcast go on YouTube let's just kind of
check her
out go type in there Nikki Haley okay
Nikki Haley and podcast all right Nikki
Haley and podcast what podcast has she
gone on okay if you were to look her up
okay what podcast has she done I don't
see any podcasts so you know what that
tells you so the average person that's
listening to this you know what Nikki
Haley is telling you you're not good
enough for her to come and talk to you
because if you're a podcast listener if
you're listening to this if you're not a
mainstream cable listener she's trying
to tell you you're not smart enough for
her she's trying to tell you the only
people she that have earned the right to
listen to her speak are the people that
are on mainstream media that's what
she's telling you now may be wrong maybe
she's going to go on the podcast or no
now but she doesn't want to do it listen
it do do I think the same STIs loves
doing podcast I think he hates it I
think he can't stand doing podcast
personally I think he doesn't stand he
can't stand doing podcast has he done
him yes do I applaud him yes you know
why cuz he's willing to go talk to you
okay do I think RFK likes doing podcast
I think he does because I think RFK is
that confident I think RFK is put me
down anywhere I'll talk to anybody do I
think Trump is willing to go and sit
down with anybody and talk to anyone
100% any day the week he's not afraid of
sitting down with anybody go sit down
with anyone Nikki Haley I I want to like
you I want to trust you but the Vibes
you give me is you look down at people
who consume podcast shows and uh you
think you're above it again maybe I'm
wrong you just give me that Vibe of an
elitist entitled has been controlled by
the people of all education and decrees
and i' I've spoken to so many Insurance
Executives like her last 20 years and
they are some of the most annoying
people to talk to I may be wrong again
I'm willing to be wrong I'm willing to
sit down and say D I actually like this
girl I actually like how she is but she
gives me the Vibes that you guys down
there you know like in these corporate
Executives on the 43rd floor they never
come downstairs to shake hands because
oh it's the peasants it's the peasants
that's the vibe I get I it's not it's
not attractive to me I I'll add this uh
you're definitely not wrong uh because I
would label I don't know I may be
wronging know judge dirty executioner
right here you're not wrong because what
who is uh feuding with Nikki more than
anybody V because one is establish
that's another name I forgot him he'll
go to any podcast anybody he's in
restaurant
clocking that guy will go anywhere out
house you can tell that guy loves and by
the way he's richer more successful more
educated smarter corre and he'll still
talk to anybody because look at it this
way if you just want to juxtapose Nikki
versus VC VC will go anywhere he'll go
in any podcast in mainstream he'll Feud
with anybody Nikki's establishment she's
going on the mainstream media she's so
much more establishment than Ronda
santis is okay she's going nowhere she's
the anti-c that's why those two are
feuding so much I know that Trump called
her bird brain she's definitely not
Birdbrain but she's definitely a war
hawk okay my biggest concern with Nikki
is that she's willing to go attack Iran
basically go to war with China with
Taiwan defend Israel fund Ukraine she's
basically halberton times on steroids
okay so do I think that that Trump would
pick her to be the VP I don't do I think
that if he did call she would pick that
she would pick up that phone call 100% I
think she's an opportunist I think that
she's um someone who's basically looking
to social climb or politically climb and
I think she's also sort of the an the
exact opposite of Pence I don't see her
being a bootlicker for Trump I I well
first of all I don't think he would pick
her but if he did actually pick her I
would lose a lot of respect for him
because he's claimed from the beginning
to drain the swamp she is the swamp Okay
and by the way if he does if if that
does happen and he goes through I would
have a food tester on all the I wouldn't
trust that girl at all because guess
what God forbid if they go after him and
for some reason they impeach cuz you
know that's what's going to happen right
when he gets in if he gets in you think
she's going to P she's going to come
going to pull an LBJ she'll pull dude
why wouldn't she because then I don't
know about that all I'm saying is but
she becomes a president I'm just saying
I don't trust her I get that I just to
me she just gives me like I you know you
go to to these parties networking
parties and you're talking to people and
like yeah so yeah and they give you that
look you know the look so so they walk
they have
[Laughter]
this okay yeah okay yeah so you went
over I went to the school the
like a
to me you know Pat's fired up if he uses
listen I can't stand elitists I mean I'm
with you I cannot stand elitist I can't
stand people that they think they're
above other human beings she gives the
vibe of thinking she's better than other
people and it's not attractive I'm
telling you right now it's not
attractive when when you're able to do
something like that you you know you're
not willing to go talk to people because
you think you're who and and what who
convinced you of that we choose you
don't choose but somebody has convinced
her to believe that's what it is so that
could be it could be the people behind
where it's the consults it could be the
money people go ahead yeah I think you
hit it but you were about to say it pat
you're exactly right I'll give you four
words Consultants control establishment
arrogance follow the line so
unattractive all the Consultants are out
there that make millions of dollars and
they make a percentage of the ad spend
what do they do they want to control the
candidate and they want to control what
they're doing and they are going to
traditional media making bid big ad buys
going on TV the over the weekend says
I'm not getting return on TV so I'm
putting my money into the marketing
efforts and things that give me a return
where I can see that I'm moving votes to
me so Consultants they want to control
the candidate in the advertising
establishment they want to go to
establish meeting media there's no value
for them to come here the consultant
value the the candidates if they
understood the depth and passion and
emotion and our ability to move votes
and what's happening with podcast they
would be at they would be there be a
line at the door every morning but
instead that's not it and guess what
when you put those three together it's
the arrogance of Yer negotiate with them
you it's right you can't negotiate the
arrogance of yesterday Consultants
control
establishment it's old you you you've
sat in room nor negotia of people like
this Tom how how are they to negotiate
with it's impossible it was terrible you
know the the first I remember meeting
some and there's a couple that don't
give names I'm not going to do there's a
couple where I didn't feel there was a
racial element because there was some
Racial equality at the table um other
times I thought is this just is this
maybe racial other times it was just man
this is just arrogance and then I would
get to things where you and I would talk
in the elevator afterwards and I'd be
like good Lord these people need to get
out more the new America that we were
bringing to them for for was a diverse
consumer it's unattractive and it was
and then by the time he gets to Lobby I
I said okay it's not racial it's not you
know uh you know the difference between
it's not ignorance it's just arrogance
you know what's the difference between
him and uh the S her and the santis
what's the difference between her and
the santis he actually is I mean they
both wear high
heels if okay I mean well it's not even
baseball season that one's over the I
had to I had what's the biggest
difference what's the biggest difference
between the santis and Haley the santis
was at least willing once or twice yeah
to to dip his toe in the water with um
some of the podcast this one and others
we
know and you know when I saw that you
know and she and she won't even touch it
and you know when I saw it but you know
when I saw that arrogance that elitist
that you're talking about when V was
holding her foot to the fire and
checking her the was just on her she
wasn't looking there and she was like
like she I I felt that Vibe of I'm
better than this I'm not even going to
respond to what's the biggest difference
you are scum I I trust the santis I
trust the santis I just think the santis
is not good on camera but I trust him I
think he's a good guy I I I don't relate
to elitist snobby I'm better
than you to come and talk to the average
person type of people and that's her I
mean my brand when I look at her in my
eyes when I look at her brand that's her
brand her brand is I'm better than you
I'm smarter than you I'm the elitist I
make the decisions you follow my lead I
know what's good for you I I don't let
me ask you this yeah okay so let's put
Trump aside for a second we see that
that you've interviewed to santis we've
had vac here we've had RFK here you've
experienced with these people clearly
you're not a fan of Nikki or at least
the elitist mentality approach I'm not
and I don't think I don't think that's
the way to win okay yeah so you see in
the polls uh she's plus five on Biden
right so Trump is a little
closer if in a million years somehow and
I don't see this necessarily happening
it could happen Nikki vers Biden would
you even consider Biden question is that
just asking what kind of a question you
just laid into Nikki I'm not I'm not
laying into Nikki that I she if it's her
against Biden what what are we talking
about there no all I'm saying to her is
your brand Nikki your Camp whoever
whoever that's watching this you guys
come across as arrogant conceited
elitist and it's unattractive to a guy
who loves America who worked his ass off
in America you come across as elitist
arrogant you're better than me and I
don't like it period if that's you and
it's always been like you it's
unattractive and I don't think I'm alone
I don't think I'm alone I think there's
other people that feel the same way as
as I do on the way you guys are that's
what I say if it's her against Biden
it's not even a question because what
what Biden's done to America last three
years is a show so that's not even
a conversation I would be having I just
don't like like listen with my kids if
my kids give a sign a single we went out
to dinner the other day a relative that
doesn't live with us okay this was two
months ago gen will remember
this this relative that we see once
every other year or something like that
and we take him out to a nice dinner
this relative goes like this excuse me
oh my god oh no to the Sur
Adam the the waiter looks at me oh God
and is so polite and gentle and kind to
to the person because that's with me
mhm and the waiter leaves my kids are
sitting at the
table if you already know how I feel
right now you have no idea how I feel
just telling you a story right now my
pain I can tell so the waiter leaves I
look at the person and I look at my kids
and I say listen never for the rest of
our lives do we go like this to a person
that's working to make the food better
for us we don't ever talk like that
again and I looked at the person I said
we don't do that I don't know if you do
that we don't do that kind of stuff you
pull them out right there in front of my
dad in front of Jen in front of
everybody and this is a person we love
and it's a relative
I said we don't do stuff like this and I
said Tio Dyan I swear to God if you ever
behave like that in front of me you
don't even know what would happen if you
behave like that in front of me we don't
do stuff like this then I got up and I
walked past to the wait and I say hey
just going to let you know this is my
table it rep represents me we don't talk
like that to people Mak sense I give him
a 50% tip so he don't have to he
understands that the respect that we got
for them she gives me the Vibes of this
I don't like that I don't like that
and to me uh I don't roll like that you
got to give people respect I'm a voter
everybody else is a voter when a person
so why do people love Joe why do people
love Dana think about the people that we
why do people love Elan because they're
authentic they're real they say but they
have the they have the ability to be an
to you yes they have the ability
to be like this and they're like hey how
you doing yep well wait a minute who are
you you just because you're on a debate
stage and and and you went and sat on
the board and you got a few million
dollars from boing this is what you want
to do n man that's not what the last
thing we need on America right now is a
this kind of a mindset we need a mindset
how you doing so what's on your mind
what do you think what's going on that's
what we need in America today we don't
need we don't need any of this stuff
unless if you're dancing if you're
dancing go like this all day I don't
care if you want to do at a Persian
wedding all day long do it and and and
I'll add to that and amplify it with
with personal experience if she's doing
this Nikki if you're doing this CU
you're being led by the Consultants
you're being coached into this this is
not the path to the heart of the average
American and the people that need
leadership in this country I met you
with Beth vany at the event in Dallas
Texas we talked for about 15 minutes
with an Associate of mine that we were
there and I didn't get this vibe from
you at all and now what I see and what I
see in the candidate I'm with Pat it's
like oh oh is this is this the way it's
going to be and if you're listening to
these Consultants cuz there's a lot of
dogs out there these Consultants that
are charging millions of dollars taking
a skim off the ad bu you know this is
not what America needs and if this isn't
who you are and you really want to
connect with the people it needs to
start now unattractive anyways okay uh
let's go to the next story uh let's see
which one let's do this one here this
one's uh very interesting and it's going
to cause many of you guys to want to
move to California uh and by the way I
just looked at the order God knows how
many of you ordered it I it's about to
we would still ship it out to you but
it's about to sell out gang those of you
guys here's what I said to you this what
we're doing for today's
podcast we called it the year of chaos
2024 it's already a chaotic year anybody
who orders just today this is not going
to be the rest it's just today because
it's the it's the first podcast of the
year I want everybody to sport the
future looks bright I don't want to give
the people that are the fear porn people
the benefit of the doubt I want leaders
to stand up and give confidence to
everybody the statement of the Year this
year is future looks bright all day long
if you order one of these futur looks
bright hats uh rob you got the whole
thing the the discount code pbd podcast
2024 all lowercase together I'm going to
drop in another hat like this and a
future looks bright hat for for us to
support I want you to go to work I want
you to go to the gym I want you to go
outside for people to say you really
think the future looks bright absolutely
why cuz we're leaders cuz we're leaders
so go place the order we still got a few
of these left specifically these the
camos the one that I like to wear future
looks bride I'll put the link below for
people to have as well okay California
becomes the first state to offer health
insurance to all undocumented immigrants
starting J January 1st California will
offer health insurance through medical
to all undocumented immigrants
regardless of age their expiration will
uh make expansion will make
approximately 700,000 undocumented
residents between ages 26 to 49 eligible
for full coverage California has
gradually expanded health coverage for
undocumented immigrants over the years
starting with children in 2015 and
expanding access to young adults 1925
and 2019 the state views this expansion
as commitment to healthcare as human
right while there have been concerns
about the strain on the medical system
and provider access issues Studies have
shown that undocumented immigrants use
fewer Healthcare resources than un than
non-immigrants Tom thoughts on this with
California there's a couple things going
on here and people need to hear the
truth
this is a campaign slogan coming out of
the mouth of Gavin Nome they have been
providing Health Care coverage to
undocumented immigrants for years there
have been major hospitals and Pat and I
come from La so we know a little bit
about La you know well covered in the LA
Times well known down there King Drew
Medical Center which is now closed has
been replaced by MLK downtown Hospital
providing critical care to people that
come in from everything from an overdose
to a um undocumented immigrant who's
trying to get you know some some care
and coverage for a child with pneumonia
and they're not turned away and instead
what happens is that was provided under
medical which is basically Medicaid in
California is called medical it's you
know Medicaid we all know what that is
that's basically um health care provided
to people who are are in poverty or too
poor to afford it and so what's
happening now oh we're just going to
give you health insurance officially
through Medical but it was already being
covered by the state because the
hospitals didn't turn them away but what
the state has done to the hospitals is
turn down what they're willing to pay
for the service oh and x-ray we're only
going to give you $11 for that and what
happens is when the state says okay
you're all getting Health Care coverage
yay if my I'm an undocumented person my
kid breaks his ankle playing soccer he
can go to a hospital and get coverage
that on a human side is good right now
it's not good that they're undocumented
and hear other stories there but now the
hospital's told yeah you get $1 for the
X-ray and $54 to uh put the bone back
and then um give you $75 for the cast
the hospital looks at it it cost me $35
just to have them walk in this place and
I'm going to get1 175 back and if you
scan down here is an article from the LA
Times about himalay Hospital says it
could soon be unable to pay its bills
why go to paragraph number four here we
go 1 two 3 one of the biggest challenges
is the fact that emergency department
has been deluged Deluge means flood
overwhelmed with four times as many
patience as initially expected that's a
problem because wait wait wait here it
comes how are we giving the the
undocumented health insurance through
medical Here Comes medical because
medical the California Medicaid Program
does not fully cover the cost for
providing emergency services so Gavin
Nome is bankrupting his own hospitals
for the sake of a headline to look good
to the voting block are you kidding me
Tom I'm out H so so how do how do you do
how do you do this and so so I'm a
hospital owner I own a hospital okay I
come back and say hey dude what are you
doing you in a hospital with a permit in
California and I will not sign your
permit unless you take medical and take
how do you expect me to stay profitable
I don't care if you want your permit P
Mr B David sign here but but what but
how do I stay in business that's not my
problem Mr B David I will pay you this
much for services I then then if that's
the case I think the hospitals are going
to come together and they're going to
say you you're out of your mind they're
they're going to have a conversation
with them to say are you want us to shut
down hospitals King Drew went out of
business and was replaced by MLK
Hospital a major Hospital in the shadow
of USC in the shadow of UCLA big medical
schools went out of freaking business
and was replaced by MLK hospital um you
know I used to think that SoCal it stood
for Southern California but it's become
clear and clearer that it stands for
socialist California you know I I used
to always get I used to get California
yeah exactly I used to get in arguments
with our friend Ricky and he would be
like all the Democrats bro and I was
like yeah I don't I don't see that in
Florida at all you know how it is here
like most people are pretty moderate
here in Florida and I didn't really
understand the the the the the the Deep
Divergence of how left and right people
in California there's a deep deep divide
there because the Socialist programs
that have basically come in in cforia as
Ricky calls it is so palpable that just
doesn't exist here in Florida that way
that why Ricky and I would always argue
be like why do you hate the Democrats so
much because I see what's going on in
California with the Trans stuff the
Socialist stuff and now the medical
stuff that's going on here we're in
Florida that doesn't exist as Ronda
Santa says you know Florida is where
woke Goes To Die California is woke was
where woke goes to live survive what
going on there everything that the
santis did with basically the trans
stuff and basically the the commercials
we all know what happened right there
but when it comes to to healthc care
obviously one of the biggest issues
Obamacare Trump John McCain the thumbs
down we all know what happened there but
you know the question of whether Health
Care is a right or a privilege you know
still unanswered but what we do know on
that is this that government run healthc
care is a recipe for disaster talk to
anybody in Canada that wants some good
dream like it's a disaster out there
talk to anybody that runs with you know
get the government out of my bedroom get
the government out of my
uh uh hospital room anything that goes
on with that universal healthcare would
be a disaster I didn't fully understand
that situation from a national
perspective but let's look at um
California as a case example to see what
happens you got to keep your voters
healthy though that's why he's doing
private companies compete you got to
keep your voters healthy but listen I I
said this jokingly earlier but it's
exactly what it is so imagine if all of
a sudden Apple started giving
non-employees ID cards to enter the
building they're going to eat everything
so think about what I just said hey
moving forward Apple a privately a
public L held company $3 trillion
company give or take we're going to
offer everybody in copertino an ID to
come into our cafeteria whether you're
an employee or not tell me logically how
that makes any sense purely logically
doesn't it doesn't make any sense a
perfect example what do you mean you're
going to offer immigrants who are not
here legally the same benefits of the
people that work to come here legally
tell me how that ID card makes any sense
what is the a big deal of me being a
California resident so if that doesn't
work for a company how does that work
for a state well those are two different
things how are the two different things
who's still paying for it somebody has
to pay for it they're not coming here
spending the money who's paying for it
tax you you I'm paying forward you and I
are paying forward Pat where's your
empathy where's your heart way but
that's what I'm saying that's the
argument no but here's my thing though
and and you just made a great point the
people of California are going to do
nothing about it what he going to sit on
your hands and not do it's the
people's responsibility to say hell no
yeah he's the governor he makes the the
final decision where are the people at
you should be Fe dud California should
be lining up not for a a climate protest
and I'm we're going to stay in the road
because you know the whales are dying no
get in the goddamn streets sorry that
the lord's name in vain and fight for
are you crazy I'm paying for somebody
that doesn't belong in the country let
me let me give you the good news at the
very least the good news is this if you
look at what's going on on our border no
one's coming across there's no Caravans
of people basically running that doesn't
exist it's not a problem story so why
are we even worried about like this guys
drop let's put let's put this right at
the end and ladies and gentlemen if
you're not voting you're an idiot
because when that hospital closes that
emergency room is not available for you
with full health insurance and a credit
card to pay the deductible either either
all right here we go here's on the On
the Border semi sarcastic comment Adam
was making here we go Democrat Democrat
mayors of Chicago New York and demma
reach breaking points from migrant surge
New York City Eric Adams emphasized the
strain on the city's resources stating
just last week we had
39 3,900 people who arrived here if you
do the math that's potentially 16,000 a
week uh uh 16,000 a week a month that we
must feed clothe house and educate that
is what the breaking point looks like
Chicago Brandon Johnson highlights the
economic burden on the city saying we
have reached a critical point in that
miss this mission that absent real
significant intervention immediately our
local e econ economies are not designed
and built to respond to this kind of
Crisis oh really oh really Denver's
Mayor Johnson then reveals a backlock of
court dates for Asylum Seekers until 20
ready 27 resulting a potential cost of
$16
million nearly 10% of the city's budget
what percent 10% of the city's budget
holy crap exactly so so then White House
of course you know because this is not
really that big of a deal no White House
says border surge Is Not Unusual you
know the White House Down plays the
current play surge of migrants at the
border describing it as a seasonal
phenomenon press secretary Katherine
Karine jeanpierre stated and we're you
know we're at a time of the year well
you know where we're seeing more at the
border I mean come on folks and it's not
unusual this is immigration system that
has been broken for decades despite
record-breaking numbers of Border
Encounters in recent months with daily
arrests ready 10,000 not not not
Crossing daily arrests 10,000 the White
House maintains that there's nothing
unusual about the situation the 8 to
10,000 migrants Caravan heading to the
border is dwindling in numbers but many
migrants are finding alternative
transportation methods to reach the
boorder nothing to see here let me say
something there's two lines in here I
want to see two lines Chicago's Brandon
Johnson absent real quote quote absent
real significant intervention
immediately translation make this
immigration stop that's what he's saying
absent real significant okay White House
systems have been broken for decades oh
it's not our fault it's been broken for
decades yeah Rob I'm going to have you
pull this up but don't pull it up yet so
we all know that far right-wing um
mainstream Media company we you already
not know it in your head um they
commented it was their main story over
the weekend okay um Rogue these are
these are the headlines that they did
Rob don't pull it up until I tell you
Rogue buses drop off migrants by the
thousands in major cities with little
notice okay Rogue buses December migrant
surge at the southern border the largest
in more than two decades okay um migrant
Crossings are spiking see what it looks
like on the southern border wow they
live in San Diego migrants pass with
their back hurts almost daily obviously
this right-wing media okay is just
trying to enhance their message here and
who is Adam fox fox always says this
what's your point Rob please pull up the
mainstream media outlet that basically
was pulling this up this was on the
cover of CNN guys Rogue buses okay this
isn't your Fox News Breitbart Drudge
Report reporting okay this is freaking
CNN over the weekend basically saying
yeah nothing to see here guys no there's
something to see here what it turns out
to be is these Sanctuary cities are are
are basically Heming they cannot take
all these migrants so when you see the
White House and your good friend your
dear friend
Karine jeanpierre basically say nothing
to see here numbers are not spiking I'm
sorry leftwing Outlets as including CNN
are reporting this okay James o'keef
Ashley stclair friends of ours they're
they're they're going down to the Border
they're seeing what's going on at the
airports they see what's happening so uh
the veil has been lifted my friends oh
by yeah go Kush go oh I was just going
to say too I've been I've been seeing
videos they did did they did one report
on it on Fox that people that are living
in New York taxpaying you know good
Americans having apartments migrants are
showing up to their doors knocking on
the door begging and asking for food I
just sent Rob another video of downtown
Manhattan Venezuelan illegals that are
in the country in New York they don't
want to stay in the hotel because
they're they're buying um five five to
like six hot plates like uh those those
heated things for food time and then
they're selling them to construction
workers it's shorting the hotels of all
electricity look at this dude this
dude's recording in New York they're
they took over his uncle 16-wheeler and
they're living in the 16-wheeler just
play till you can show the kid Rob look
Patrick that's that's this is where
that's in New York these migrants look
at that little kid they're living inside
of the back of 16 wheelers and he's like
they're using the money for a scratch
off lottery tickets underneath can't
physically go into that trailer with
children they can't go in there we
cannot physically lock the trailer cuz
children are in and we definitely can't
drive away with the trailer the whole
family does the baby have J on
to figure out what's going on to make
these guys want to live in the like
someone suggested I have those those are
Jordan we went there now you can pause
it for one second so so Adam basically
they're they're illegals they're in the
hotel that they're they're letting them
stay in but they're hooking up all these
hot plates to sell to cons I get the
hustle is is is there it's shorting all
the electricity so they'd rather leave
and not be by the rules and live in some
that's some guy's property and then if
the once the video keeps going you don't
have to play Rob there's 30 to 40
scratch off tickets they they got money
they have cell phones and they're
chilling it's like when are we going to
admit like enough is enough mayorcas and
all these rats they don't care bro and
and now we're at the point of no return
how many have come in so far 8 million
in these past three the problem is we
don't know the numbers we know that it's
more than ever and it's insane that
people aren't getting mad about
something like this people get more mad
about trans rights than like this this
is going to come B this is a way bigger
issue than than Dylan mulany if I could
add one more thing goe there's a couple
different things going on here number
one the vast majority of these people
are basically fleeing their countries
because there's there's just economic
wos and no ability to make money there
if you want further proof that
capitalism is better than communism look
no further of why of who's coming to
this country so the number one country
and it's not even close is Venezuela
Venezuelans hardworking Hispanics are
friends that dude I know I have a ton of
Venezuelan friends amazing they are
fleeing communist socialist Maduro
shavez regime to get the hell out of
there yes they're coming from Cuba yes
they're coming from Haiti yes they're
coming from Guatemala shout out to Mario
yes they're coming from huras yes
they're coming from Nicaragua but the
vast majority of these people are coming
from Venezuela because they have no the
they have no economic ability to
basically move up to totem pole but then
here's the caveat and electricity and
water on and off all day but here's the
cave out here we just named all those
countries and they're fleeing them
because of
poverty why are people from Russia
coming in why are people from China
coming in why are people from Iran
coming in what's going on here in this
situation because they've caught people
from other countries other than these
Central American and South American
count that Adam they're coming because
they know guess what what's another
incentive nobody's going to stop you
you're going to come in and oh by the
way if you go to California that that
guy with the slick back hair he's giving
you free insurance what do you why
wouldn't you want to come how many more
incentives and oh and by the way it's
all a plan because now once the election
starts coming at they want to do
something that kind of disrupt
everything all those people that you're
talking about from all these different
countries there's terrorists That 160
that we've caught that are already here
waiting just waiting for the go and
that's that's the year talking about the
year of chaos just wait and see just
wait and see what's going to happen and
meanwhile meanwhile the white head says
the Border surges Not Unusual and nobody
checks her when nobody has the balls
nobody has the balls during that press
briefing to raise their hand and go hey
Karine with one of your lazy eyes you're
full of you're lying if it was
during you went after her eyes I hate
everything you could do you went after
the I she bothers me so much because she
you know what a strategy it is when
you're playing poker
what
wow you can't you can't listen what did
Scarface say it's in the eyes the yeah
let's go to the next one I cannot
believe you went after the ice but okay
all right so let's go to the next one
here can't stand there all right for
happiness you ready in a New Year stop
overdoing everything you're working too
hard folks this is what this writer from
Wall Street Journal is telling us let's
see let's see what this feedback in this
council is maybe we ought to just just
take the day off by putting yourself
through so much stress press here we go
each New Year people tend to overcommit
to self-improvement goals and engage in
self-defeating behaviors referred to as
the overs such as overworking
overreaching you know
overthinking driven by need for psych
psychological Safety Research indicates
that overachieving and overthinking do
not necessarily lead to better
performance instead they are associated
with mental and physical health issues
such as anxiety depression addiction
overfunctioning can become a harmful
cycle where the brain craves more
overdoing to break free by the way I
don't know how your body is feeling so
far but I'm I want to meet this person
leave to break free from the grip of
overs individuals can set new boundaries
tolerate temporary discomfort
differentiate between danger and dislike
and recognize that they are ultimately
responsible for their own sense of
safety and well being leading to a
healthier and more Balanced Life Adam
why did you want the story look there's
a lot going on here um so everyone makes
New Year's resolutions okay we all know
that everyone's going to work out
everyone's going to do their best
they're going to eat healthier
everyone's going to save more money did
you know that actually the second
Tuesday of the month second Friday of
the month is a national holiday called
quitters day quitters day is a day look
it up Rob where basically people
basically said yeah I've already quit
all my New Year's resolutions it's time
to get back on the ball over here oh God
okay so quitters day there it is right
there quitters day does second Friday in
January Falls in January 12th this year
basically basically when all your
resolutions go out the window but here's
what I would argue for happiness
happiness to me is having meaning and
purpose to your life a lot of people
basically think that happiness is just
sort of just this thing where they just
I'm just going to oh someone's
going to do the cona happened
send it to Mead I don't want to distract
happiness is doing the conga it I will
give you that it is but um everyone's so
obsessed with work life balance but I
would argue that work gives you purpose
work gives you meaning work basically
working with the team accomplishes
something so I this I might go on a
little rant here right now the biggest
we talked about the covid issue of being
the sort of the uh generational Health
crisis of our time there's a bigger
Health crisis that nobody's talking
about or at least we're not paying the
most attention to it um that as we
should and that is a me Mental Health
crisis among the youth uh Meet the Press
Kristen Welker you know good friend of
yours V I love her she'd actually did a
great expose um of what's going on in
this country especially among the youth
the Surgeon General of America called
called it the youth mental H youth
Mental Health crisis the defining Public
Health ISS issue of our time here's some
numbers for you when to talk about
happiness work life balance this is why
you need meaning and purpose in your
life the lifetime depression rates in
2015 were 19% 2023 29% whoa okay uh
adults who have say a family member has
experienced severe mental health crisis
51% of adults here in America today us
suicides all-time high in 2023 12
million adults have thought about
suicide and 1.7 have attempted suicide
but okay veterans you guys two veterans
right here the Veterans Crisis Line has
a record number of calls this year when
you talk about depression anxiety
whether it's made up or whether it's
real it's pervasive in this country at
this point but the reason to that the
reason there a youth Mental Health
crisis it all comes down to social media
is this is what they've attributed to
persistent feelings of sadness and
hopelessness among teenagers in high
school 57% of young women
57% 29% of men so double women okay 4 42
States here in America uh their attorney
generals 42 out of 50 states in America
have sued meta because they're the owner
of Facebook they're the owner of
Instagram we know this they have sued
meta for basically what they've done
with Instagram and Facebook 95% of of
kids under 17 teenagers use social media
35% use it constantly so when we talk
about these crisis these Health crisises
the the whatever happened with Co the
biggest problem what's happening with
America's youth so I know this is a
conversation about happiness but
happiness comes from having meaning and
purpose in your life and a lot of young
people don't have jobs they don't have
careers they're still in high school and
they're on social media every single day
and they're just not
happy absolutely for happiness in the
New Year stop overdoing things America
start with your kids and put put them on
time budgets on social media and online
living online and staring into the
digital box for their ratifications and
for their affirmation which is what
likes followership and everything else
about social media is about is why those
42 AGS went after meta for good reason
it's time to build a thing called what's
it called what's it called a
relationship a relationship with your
kids see that your kids have
relationships with other good kids
cuz overdoing everything yeah let's stop
with the overdoing online and overdoing
social media and then Focus they pick a
sport they like they pick an after
school activity they like and they focus
on that focus is a when they say
overdoing everything I disagree with
part of that because when your kid
focuses on something I've had kids that
focus on things not the same things I
focused on I didn't guide it I let God
show me what were the proclivities of my
girls and they were very different from
one another and I get them to focus on
that and I give them support and I keep
them off of the of the digital sus pool
and by the way you know it's crazy two
days if you remember uh Vinnie uh I
don't know if it was Aspen or if it was
when we came came back uh titico watched
social
dilemma and I said so what you think
about it he said I thought it was very
interesting I said what you think was
very interesting well said well I see
how people are spending way too much
time on social media and da d d and you
know he's just kind of like processing
get
himself but I think the part about first
of all this message here with this uh uh
Wall Street Journal story about over
this over that over this knock it off
anything big you ever do you're
overdoing you know when you're having
kids you know hey you're pregnant don't
over pregnant yourself because under
pregnant yourself what the what do you
want me to do I'm pregnant like all I'm
thinking about is being pregnant when
you're doing a startup don't over
startup yourself under startup yourself
no you're supposed to over prepare
you're supposed to over achieve over any
of that stuff versus just trying to be
one of these you know no one and by the
way the person that wrote this article
in Wall Street Journal you would not
have a job with Wall Street Journal if
the person that started Wall Street
Journal wasn't overdoing it just so you
know that okay and you wouldn't have a
platform to have this be shared at on
Google YouTube on this podcast if
somebody wasn't overdoing it Julia just
so you know that so yes I totally get it
and I hope it's working for you with
your family and everything else that
you're
doing but that doesn't apply to almost
anything big that happens in life
Somebody went above and beyond to overdo
it you know we finished a took Tio
yesterday to the movies and we watched
this new rowing movie I don't know if
you've seen this new rowing movie yeah
the rowing movie that comes out about
1930s in Great Depression they're broke
and these kids come out of nowhere and
they're the junior team and they end up
winning State and then they end up
winning the Nationals and then they go
to the Olympics and they beat Germany
wow and it's the most most incredibly
Underdog this guy's sitting next to me
crying I'm like dude what are you crying
for he's like I just joined a rowing
group at 56 years old I I relate to this
cuz he show me the app 1.5 million rows
I've done and look at what these kids
did wow these guys had to overdo it cuz
they didn't have a choice Julia some of
us didn't go to a good school cuz our
parents couldn't afford to send us to a
good school we don't have the choice of
under or stagnant we have to do over and
by the way when you living a life that
you're you're you have this feeling of
things can be taken away from you you're
always staying in that little bit of the
paranoid mindset right you're always
staying in the little bit of the all of
this stuff could be taken away from me
what if I don't have this anymore it
almost causes you a little bit to be
what to have perspective to have
gratitude and to realize man I'm so
lucky to have what I have right now you
stop being arrogant and cocky about
losing certain friends you stop being
arrogant and Cocky by losing certain
relatives you stop being arrogant and
Cocky by losing certain opportun unities
I'm willing to say it's actually a very
good place to be at by the way Rob can
you pull up that man thing that Kelly
sent you with the different pictures in
the last week okay in if I tell you
during Christmas within a week I did
over a hundred mans with different
people okay the stories the most
incredible stories this guy just sent me
man today I did two mans on man you get
to ask me any questions myself Tom
Vinnie Adam any questions you may have
you can send it in a text or an audio or
a face time and have a conversation with
one guy wanted to ask about hey you know
I'm a $500 million company I've built
what do I do right now with the next
phase that I want to go through exit
this other guy sends me a message today
I'm going through challenging times my
father died at his funeral 3,000 people
showed up within 24 hours to his funeral
can you imagine 3,000 people show you're
having conversations about parenting
money Finance man is officially the app
built by influencers for influencers
where you get to DM somebody and you get
a respond back my last 150 messages I
responded back on Manet they're all
audio which means I respond back to you
in audio I think so do you so do you so
do Tom any questions you want to ask we
just cross 100,000 downloads on man this
is officially becoming a networking app
because you can DM people on Instagram
they don't have to get back to you and
they don't ever get back to you 95% of
the time people don't get back to you on
linkon and Instagram you know why never
what's in it for them on man they'll get
back to you because you're paying for
resp resp and if they they're responding
back to you isn't valuable enough you
get to put a one star or a two star or a
three star or if they give you a
valuable response you're like my gosh
that was a great feedback here's a five
star review you get to see on my next so
I'm I'm officially addicted to this app
man it's the first app I check every
morning when I wake up yeah and and said
but before uh we go it mind you I'm a
comedian I'm an actor I'm a writer okay
whatever whatever I've gotten I've
gotten video calls from people that
didn't have nothing to do with comedy
and it was just life like I'm talking
about life or death type stuff where I
gave them advice I'm not a professional
in that field but just the conversation
and what happened with this person and
where they are right now bro I I I don't
want to say names or what the
circumstance was but I I wasn't I was
like why me of all people he was just
like I cuz I know that he needed
somebody toughed by he's got all the
money in the world he's like I just
needed somebody to basically punch me in
the face and I knew it was going to be
you and the guy is doing way better than
he is like I don't want to say anything
to again it's ridiculous the app is it's
it's ridiculous that's awesome I look
man has been incredible uh for the for
the people that ask questions that that
that need answers the people we do phone
calls with but it's been even more
incredible for us because we want to
hear from you we help you with your
problems some of the best some of the
best conversations there's people that
I've when I when I first met them uh
they were struggling and now they're
thriving and it's amazing and they
they've enhanced their careers they've
enhanced their life it's so rewarding
for both sides of the equation and these
are things that no DM is ever going to
do amazing and I want to give one major
shout out shout out to the attorney that
upcharged you for the half instead of
the 8 minutes okay Pat cuz that guy
basically created a boohemoth a monster
called man that's how this whole thing
got started guy I had a 7even minute
call with a lawyer Y and he charged me
for 30 minutes said why are you charging
me 30 minutes he says minutes roll up I
said I want to pay you by the minute he
says that thing doesn't exist eventually
we launched an app called minut do you
have a minute to connect let's man and
now man's all over the place so use the
QR code who you whoever you want to talk
to up test it out send a message to
Vinnie Tom myself um uh uh or others
there's a bunch of other people on there
as well me too Pat thanks yes and Adam
next story all right let's go to the
next story here and we can go to uh
let's go to the boxing one USA boxing to
allow trans women to compete against
female boxers what US boxing has
introduced a transgender policy allowing
male boxers who transition to compete in
the female category starting in 2024
athletes must meet specific criteria
including declaring their new gender
identity undergoing gender reassignment
surgery and providing regular hormone
testing for a minimum of four years
following surgery the policy comes after
the international Olympic Committee
ioc ruled in 2021 that each sport and
its governing B should decide how to
address transgender athlete
participation the move has generated
mixed reactions as female athletes have
raised concerns about competing against
transgender women citing feeling of
being scared and unsafe finny I I I
genuinely thought last year towards the
end of 2023 the whole Trends especially
with the trend trans Sports thing was
kind of dying down they're doubling down
and like and and I want to ask one thing
so well let me let me tell you the
actual policy so miners under the age of
18 must compete as their birth gender
all right thank God they're at least
doing that and way class is outlined in
the boxing rule book USC boxing will
only communicate with minors with a
parent or League of Guardian president
but for boxers over the age of 18 that's
18 years on your birthday uh a boxer who
transitions from male to female is
eligible to compete in the female
category under these following
conditions ready the athlete has
declared that her gender identity is
female and has completed gender
reassignment surgery the athlete for a
minimum of four years after the surgery
has had cly hormone testing and presents
USA boxing documentation of hormone
levels they must demonstrate that uh her
cuz she's he's transitioned uh total
testosterone level in serum has been
below 5 NM
o/l for the past 48 months and then the
athletes total testost level and serum
must remain it has to stay low but
here's my question to you guys he this
the bone structure and the mass and the
and the he's still going to beat the
hell out of this female like can we all
agree to that I can't wait to see no I I
actually this is it's ridiculous because
now Adam because me and you are betting
guys can you bet on this can you bet and
I want to who are you going to bet on on
that fight who are you going to actually
bet on I'm on the dude that used to be a
dude that's playing the dude that's
that's why because y think about it cuz
yo your strength your bones your mask it
is unbelievable that we're having and
mind you this isn't some Rinky Dink
League this is USA but there's one thing
one thing that's happening here is good
USA boxing is saying okay enough with
the declare on Monday win on Tuesday
crap that Leah Thomas did with the uh
Ivy League championships for swimming
declare on Monday win on Tuesday yeah
they're saying four years and you have
to have gone through everything you just
examined from the surgery to longterm
hormone so what they're saying if you
are totally serious and you go through
everything and it's been 4 years okay
fight as a woman but to your point you
know height and reach are skeletal and
are still there even if you've had the
surgery to correct length even even if
you've used the dicks saws Tom likes to
say the surgery ready for this how what
what are you telling the the youth that
want to compete stuff it's like Hey
listen you could still do it just chop
off your crotch and and wait four years
and you'll fight that's not a good role
model like you know what I mean like you
know who's laughing at this Dana White
is laughing at this Dana White is
sitting there saying no wonder you are
not uh what you once were boxing what
what like can you imagine Dana White NOW
announcing okay moving forward within
UFC we're going to allow transgenders to
compete in the woman what do you think
is a likelihood of Dana doing something
like that no zero not happening
absolutely zero speaking of
laughing uh did you hear about Dave
Chappelle's newest standup bit of course
I saw it did you see it I saw the okay
so allow me to to kind of encapsulate
the story here we all know that Dave
Chappelle was calling out the trans
Community who got attacked on in Cali
that he walked off stage or something
like that or this this was part of that
that bit but so we see what's going on
with Dylan mulvania you brought up Leah
Thomas in Canada by the way now they are
now officially putting tampons in the
men not men's Boys restaurant Elementary
School Great okay cuz we all know that
us boys we get our period every month I
mean that's just obvious right all our
kids we I mean we get it so but Dave
Chappelle as he as he does he tells a
story that you don't see it coming
comedy's all about misdirection so he
tells the story I'll try to tell it in a
minute or less he goes uh huge Jim
Carrey fan hug huge fan I never met Jim
Carrey uh but my buddy uh the late great
nor McDonald was doing a movie with Jim
Carrey and he goes hey man yeah you want
to meet Jim Carrey yeah I would love to
and but they didn't tell me that he was
filming a movie at the time man on the
moon what was the movie it was Man on
the Moon now I know you're a method
actor yeah Jim Cary got so into this
role that he even when they said cut he
was still him he still was Andy Kaufman
amazing comedian Jim carre's hero so he
played him in a movie so nobody told
Dave Chappelle that Jim Carrey was not
breaking okay the Andy Kaufman thing so
he shows up and Dave Kaufman's Dave
chapelle's like Jim Carrey how you doing
like huge fan this is Dave Chapelle
fanboying over Jim Carrey and Jim
Carrey's like Yeah Hello nice to meet
you thank you Jim J's like the
I came this ain't who I thought it
was like and he says as much as this guy
tried to pretend yeah that he was
actually Andy Kaufman I knew it was that
he was Jim Carrey and he goes that my
friends is exactly how I feel about the
trans Community oh he killed them he
murdered them as much as you're trying
to be Andy Kaufman gentlemen you're
really just Jim Carrey okay as much as
you're trying to pretend that you're a
woman Dylan moaney yeah we know you got
a dick under that dress nobody's buying
it especially Dave Chappelle so only as
Dave Chappelle can do these types of
things and by the way can sell beer but
he can't box and by the way that leads
to you know you're hearing a when you
told the tampon story you're not kidding
about that story right Canada passes
laws requiring tampons in male bathrooms
they they passed laws to allow tampons
in male bathroom it's about time I mean
I was going to start saying something I
know Canadians I know Canadians I can't
so let me read this to the government of
Canada under the tutelage of prime
minister Justin Trudeau has passed a law
requiring all employees to provide
menstral products or tampons in all
federally regulated workplaces the
regulation specified that menol products
must be in all toilet rooms regardless
of their marked genders this means that
every female identified male identified
and all gender toilet rooms will need to
have menstrual products the Canadian
government's website reads it explains
that unrestricted access to menstrual
products provides greater protection for
men menstrating employees and make sure
that they feel safe to use a toilet room
the best reflects their gender it
further mandates that the all employees
must ensure the presence of a disposal
container of tampons in all restrooms
Tom when you hear hear the story by as
as a Canadian yourself how do how much
do you support Justin Trudeau's decision
here a you like it a Justin Trudeau is
Bonkers and the provinces I line up with
going to Alberta where there's a lot of
oil and beef hello albertans hello
Calgary there there are people in in
Canada that that find this Bonkers just
the way that we find it Bonkers in our
political realm and this guy comes from
basically the Bonker family because you
look back to Pierre Trudeau's dad and
Margaret Trudeau his mom I mean Castro
real nice good-looking family exact and
remember Margaret Trudeau took off for a
summer with the Rolling Stones you know
that y she took off and that's that was
our joke hey did you hear Pier Trudeau
built a patio this summer really yeah he
paid for the concrete Margaret laid the
stones so it was that's a Canadian joke
going back to the 80s by the way but I
think it's I think it's nuts I think
it's nuts and it's literally nuts it
yeah or nut less or or something it's
just Trudeau pandering to to the woke to
say here I did something it's that
freaking simple and and now it's a a
cost and an inconvenience and lunacy to
all the various building owners
everywhere they're going to have to do
this under law guys I don't have kids
yet okay you know I don't necessarily
know how the math works okay Tom you've
got two
girls Pat you've got two boys you've got
two girls I was under the impression
that all young boys get their periods
yeah I I just that's what I thought no
but you know when we were in high school
we all got I remember when we all got
our period together in gym class we all
had cramps it was so bad you but you
know going you know what this is saying
though this is saying that girls that
are like I'm a boy now are going to be
in the boy's room with dealing with
their period that's what that is you
know you know that right it's women that
are going into the men's bathroom that
need it's just F proof that the 99%
needs to basically Pander to the 1% and
when I say 1% it's like
.1% when are we going to start living in
reality when young boys have tampons and
menstrual utensils to basically when
they walk into a room when a 10-year-old
boy a 12-year-old boy who literally has
no clue what the hell that is they're
just going to be throwing them at each
other spitting them at each other like
it it it's going to be satire of the
highest level this is the movie we are
living in the movie Idiocracy if you
haven't seen that
movie it's a Sim go watch that movie and
it's literally what is going to happen
like we're almost there but it's
unbelievable that that by the way with
all the problems that that idiot did
with all the truckers and everything
that Canada is dealing with that's on
your priority list that's what you want
to do shame on that Canadians make that
tampon great again let me tell you trash
talking athletes everywhere we'll say it
right you can be a little but
you're not a girl exactly o Tom went
there Mike drop wow Bailey Brook ear
muffs please that ear muff so all right
so for the longest time when you think
about Thanksgiving uh uh games when you
have Thanksgiving what sport plays on TV
when football when you think about
Christmas Day what do you think about
for the longest time you it's always
been basketball
always well Christmas Day
was always basketball and they would
have a bunch of different things that
would happen this year it was a
different story so I post a tweet this
year I want to talk about some of the
numbers on NFL against the NBA how the
NBA is getting destroyed so I posted
this I'm glad you have it Rob perfect so
I get this from this one website I want
to give these guys proper love because
they're actually classy guys and they
reached out to me and and uh I simply
re-shared whatever was in the squore
I'll give it to him here in a minute
they they're somewhere there number
numbers don't lie the current NBA
regular season product absolutely sucks
NFL gets more viewers in one game than
NBA gets in five games combined Vinnie
ready times two watch this number go
ahead so can you pull it up a little bit
so we can see the numbers Rob NFL's
average viewership over three 2022
Christmas Day games was 21.9 million
that's the average Vinnie the average of
NBA game on Christmas day was 4. 3
million by the way during Michael that
used to be 8.8 million okay double but
it is what it is so let's go past this
Rob then go to the story check this out
with numbers George Carl decides to
respond back to me okay and he retweets
and if you don't know who George Carl is
he's got a, 1175 wins in the the Seattle
SuperSonics also Denver this guy's been
around the block no question about it
let go back to the story he retweeted it
not there you were at the right place
yeah so so right there so here's a
couple other stats from George the coach
by the way as an MLB owner your product
sucks worse than any major sport 400
million 450 million basketball uh uh
play basketball around the world and the
number is skyrocketing while 5 million
people around the world play football
and that number is plummeting numbers
don't lie the numbers don't lie the
current okay so then I responded back to
him as well they can go a little lower
there's more exchange but let me show
the numbers go up go up Rober right
there all right watch this guys this is
Christmas Day NFL decides to start
having Christmas Day games beauti look
at that
Raiders Chiefs
29.17 million damn Giants Eagles
29.02 I thought Ravens 49ers would have
been the most 27.2 3 million look at the
NBA games on Christmas Day Bucks nicks 2
and A5 million Warriors nuggets 4.1
million Celtics Lakers Vinnie Christmas
Day 5 million that's it 76ers heat only
1.3 million and MAF son you're talking
about Luca against Booker against you
know Durant 1 and A5 million people you
combine all the NBA games together times
two it still doesn't beat an NFL game
one game one game now the heer the
defending conference Champion Jimmy
buckas right nobody cared now keep going
lower keep going lower now watch this
jimy didn't play so so it gets worse if
it gets worse when I'm comparing to so
so another guy responds back and he says
that's not fair because the NBA plays 82
regular game seasons and the NFL only
plays 17 I said no problem let's do that
if the NBA averages is 4.3 million views
per game in the regular season the NFL
average is 21.9 82 * 4.3 equals 352
million views the NFL only plays 17 17 *
21.9 equals what 372 million people
George Carl being the fact that he's a
basketball guy I told Coach Carl that's
like a basketball player taking only 17
shots scoring more points than the other
guy that took 82 shots pretty
embarrassing go a little lower okay when
it comes down to the dollars keep going
when it comes down to dollars I think
it's a little bit above that with the
dollars okay here's a revenue 2022 NFL
took in $17 billion Revenue MLB the
boring sports that he's talking about
$10.5 billion doar MBA took 9.6 billion
and MLS that's a small little product
that's coming up it's at 1 A5 billion
NHL is at 4.9 billion he
asks I explain why I think this has
happening number one every league has to
decide who its number one customers I
think in the NBA the number one customer
is the player they've on the
customers they've on fans they've
shed on clients that wanted that father
that can only spend $600 a year to go to
a game to watch LeBron play he's
probably taking a day off that day that
that father that wants to take his K kid
that he can only afford to go watch one
game that guy's not going to play 82
games a season are you out of your mind
Zion takes every other game off and he's
getting paid the kind of money that he's
getting paid number two the NBA
contracts protect players more than
owners and then last but not least Point
number three Rob if you want to go to
number three if it's still there or not
the NBA went woke during covid and
became a 100% political organization
once it happened you know what happened
to their viewership last 10 years they
lost 50% of their viewership the last 10
years do you know what is the most
viewed Finals game of all time Michael
Jordan 1998 against the Utah Jazz 36 38
million people watch six when he had the
flu yeah when he push off it wasn't
Russell 36 37 38 million people you know
how many people watched the last finals
game game five or game six 12 million
people 13 million people the NBA product
is dead as of today so now Sports
business all that stuff Tom I'm going to
go to you first then I'm going to go to
you your thoughts on what's causing NBA
to do this is it dead is it NFL that
much of a better product what's going on
with the NBA today the NBA it is true
that all around the world you need you
know five pairs of sneakers and a ball
and you can play basketball and so
there's a lot of things happening
globally but here in the US market let's
just talk about the US market it's
everything you just said it doesn't
represent it's it's not aspirational for
the fan I can't remember the last time I
paid for tickets and I used to pay for
tickets all the time to go see the
Lakers play Hey Dallas is in town this
is oh my gosh let's go see Dirk you know
and I loved it I and by the way I
haven't taken my kids to NBA games uh
and and I think they've lost the heart
of the American Consumer and they're
running around the world to find new
markets to make up for it because I I
think they know the issue they got Adam
Silver knows what's going on that's why
they're trying to open up China so much
that's why they focus on all this
International openup because they see
what's happening and they can say oh
well you know the shift is streaming in
cable and all the cable companies going
out and then Hulu and YouTube TV really
NFL hasn't had any problems with
viewership it's back MLB has had a
couple strikes that have really that
that missed one World Series back in
history and baseball has always come
back eventually because they know the
customer and they're coming to the
customer to put a great package out
there but for all the reasons you've
talked about the NBA doesn't care
they're just going for rights markets
the NBA is running around trying to urge
rights money on glob television and the
glob there is a global appeal to the
sport and to the I have an idea when
it's going to change I have an idea when
it's going to change but go ahead well
there's a lot going on here and
um I mean this in the most respectful of
ways I think you stated the obvious I
think we know that the NFL is the
boohemoth that is now officially America
sport is no longer baseball but what
what I applaud is you put the numbers
behind it you put in the work it's like
we had Usman here the other day amazing
fighter right awesome ridiculous I was
like what would happen if you fought
Nagano he's like nah bro I'm not like a
heavyweight versus a middleweight or a
lightweight it's not a fair fight the
NFL especially on Christmas during the
NBA on Christmas it's not a fair fight
nobody gives a about the NBA right
now nobody gives a about the NBA
basically until basically April when the
playoffs basically start May and then it
starts happening and then the finals is
typically in June right now we're in the
end of the NFL season basically people
are jocking for positions over the next
few weeks next week is is week 18 it
used to be SE 16 weeks 17 weeks now it's
18 so there's so much stuff going on
here if you look at the world's uh most
expensive for sports franchises seven
out of the top 10 are NFL teams there's
only three non-nfl related teams in the
top 10 one we know a guy that's a part
owner of one of them called the Yankees
then you got more expensive for number
one is Dallas that's not even far you
got Yankees this is baseball Golden
State which they basically have
skyrocketed over the last decades thanks
to Steph Curry and then it's all NFL
teams Patriots Rams Giants Bears Raiders
and then at the end of the uh list is
who oh my gosh yeah Las Vegas Raiders so
but NFL is um there's you know there's
only one sport that has a day the
holiest day of the week some may say
that is dedicated now to the NFL okay
there's no day dedicated to the NBA
there's no day dedicated to baseball
Sunday is dedicated to one sport and by
the way Saturday is dedicated to college
football as well by the way shout out to
the Michigan Wolverines going to the uh
National Championship versus uh versus
Washington right there but football is
America sport days are dedicated for it
and you put the numbers behind it and of
course some someone like George Carl I'm
still waiting on I'm going to push back
bro for 5 minutes I'm waiting for a push
there's no push back there's no push
back there's no push back I'm just
saying you stated the obvious everyone
knew this you put the math behind it by
the way let me ask you a question let me
ask you a question what is a more Rob
can you put this as a poll what's a more
exciting product that you like to play
okay watch this just a viewer what
product do you like to play more put
soccer put baseball put basketball ball
put football not MLB NFL just what game
do you like to play okay I'm actually I
don't want us to answer cuz we'll
influence it I just want to know what's
going to happen within the first few
minutes because I'm willing to tell you
if you have any opinions on this do you
have anything well about this whole
situation yeah cuz you you touched on it
for one point but I think we kind of
just mold over it how much do you think
the way that the NBA handled you know
with Co and then you mentioned this in
the Tweet LeBron James being the face of
the NBA King James during all of Trump's
thing his attitude towards Trump when uh
that girl was shot and killed I forgot
um uh I forgot her her last name which
by the way the cop was exonerated LeBron
James tweeted and called for violence he
goes you're next to theop how much of
that woke kneeling for the national
anthem hold on that anti-American
sentiment just recently he walked into
the uh to a game sat on his ass and do
didn't do anything a lesson learned from
the Dylan mulany what Americans America
we don't like that crap we don't like
that anti-American stuff we don't want
you pushing your gender crap on on beer
what a how many billions of dollars did
budlight you lose on that and I'm
telling you LeBron James had a big
impact on people going cuz dude I used
to watch the NBA then all that kneeling
and all that oh everybody's racist
America sucks we're all nobody lik about
this tweet right that he took down this
tweet and he took this down you're next
and by the way this cop was acquitted
because uh of the situation where he was
legally like it wasn't he got what
happened to LeBron for tweeting this
your next accountability absolutely
nothing and you know what that is that's
a felony if you're calling for a dude if
you if you did that you're going to jail
you know that right if you pointed a
picture of a cop who's under
investigation for homicide and you say
You're Next you're calling for violence
for that cop Patrick that's a that's a
felony yeah are you crazy so do you guys
think that's a he's going to retire at
some point and I can't wait and I think
that's going to I have two things here I
have two things here two things is going
to change a game of NBA by the way
what's the voting Rob I'm just curious
to know what people are saying what
what's uh what's the if the answer
soccer I'm I'm going to be so
disappointed you then get ready to be
disappointed 35% for soccer 26% for
basketball 25% for football and 14% for
baseball okay so baseball is last okay
fine watch this here's what I will tell
you I think two things are holding the
NBA back LeBron James and Adam Silver
period bingo because David Stern was a
boss you feared him he was a liberal he
went to Columbia I believe he went to
one of those liberal schools can can you
check to see what schools David Stern
went to type in David Stern because
almost every one of these guys they're
pretty much liberal guys that want to uh
uh zoom in what LW school ruter and
Columbia there you go yeah went to
Columbia and then go to Adam Silver to
see where Adam Silver went to school I'm
curious because Harvard Adam Silver went
to uh I think also the same zoom in he
went to Chicago and Duke okay he want to
do good for him so for me these two guys
are part of the problem because uh Adam
Silver fell for a uh uh con organization
called BLM and they wrapped BLM all over
the place and we found that afterwards
that was a con job okay those guys
fooled you Adam
Silver you were naive and you fell
forward and number two is LeBron James
is a divisive face of the NBA you know
when when you think about a face of the
NBA you know who you want you want want
somebody like a I don't know like a um
who's that guy Janis jannis is you want
a Giannis you want a Brady you want a
Michael you want a Kobe you know you
know what Jordan did when it came down
to an event that happened with cops
shooting and back and forth he gave both
I think it was a Chicago PD and a black
nonprofit organization he gave each of
them 5 million bucks you know what he's
trying to say hey here's where I am okay
I I support both is that right there can
you Google that
Michael Jordan pledges to give $5
million to African-American Museum and
he gave $5 million to have le to a
police uh no no to a police some kind of
Charity that he gave it to organization
to LeBron is divisive he makes the game
unattractive he makes it unattractive to
watch unattractive to follow I haven't
followed the Lakers ever since this guy
joined the Lakers I'm just right there
is this the one yeah Michael Jordan
donates a million dollar each to
Institute of community police relations
n n NAACP you know what he's saying to
you hey guys both of you are important
go do your thing here's a million bucks
NAACP and Community Police relations I
respect the cops I respect that's the
premier example he's not telling you
he's a republican he's not telling you
he's an independent he's not telling you
he's a Democrat all he's saying is look
both of you guys here some money go do
something about it LeBron could never
ever all you have to do is come out and
give salute to our military all you have
to do is come out and give a salute to
police officers all you have to come out
and give a salute to what these guys
make you feel safe to play basketball
he's not capable of doing that and Adam
Sila unfortunately you know Roger godell
we went hard hard on Roger godell during
Colin Kaepernick but you know what Roger
did he slowly realized okay that was a
mistake let's kind of work our ways back
to here what happened to the NFL boom
back at it again right Adam Silver has
proven he's not capable of doing that
okay uh I would be you know what I'd be
curious about you know how we were at
the RNC the other day in in uh in
whatever the debate was in uh SEI Valley
okay yeah were you you were there right
and we saw a professional NBA player you
don't need to say the name but you saw
the 611 guy you're like oh and you
want to talk to him for like 20 30
minutes what are you doing here um yeah
I'm just trying to learn right I'm just
trying to learn really yeah I'm just
trying to learn that's why I'm over here
huh interesting I wonder if they did
this poll if there here's a poll I'd be
interested in is the following what
percentage of MLB players give to the
left and right what percentage of NHL
players give to the left and a right NBA
and NFL which one do you think is going
to be M majority of the money being
given to the left NBA 100% and it won't
even be close out of all those Sports it
won't even be close it'll be NBA all the
way at the top majority money being
given to Democrats and it makes sense
it's a turn off of a product and LeBron
has that is is Rich and that victim and
you talked about this with Tico and
Dylan that victimhood mentality oh it's
a like bro relax because you're not a
victim and you're making everybody feel
like they're a victim bro Americans are
ti can we talk about a real victim to
finish this podcast up so we can go yeah
let's talk about a real victim Rob can
you pull up this victim deer in Aspen
video that I sent to you can set this
can we set this up yeah go ahead and set
it up then you take so we're in Aspen
the the house that that this guy and
dude one of the best Christmases I've
had and I love you for for inviting me
man this house is like the the Dumb and
Dumber it's like the sickest house bro
it's snowing it's skiing it's everything
we're already going to go ski all right
we're we're in route Mario um is going
with Ethan and they're leaving Ethan his
son looks back and goes hey Dad I think
cuz there's two there's a pool there's
everything there's a there's a lake it's
kind of iced over and he goes I think a
deer just fell in the lake and Mar's
already leaving he's like what he's like
are you kid he goes no I'm telling you a
deer
Mario turns around gets out uh the chef
uh Alper he comes out and he's recording
this and just to throw this out there
Mario is an aspen he's a gualin dude
okay and out of nowhere he yells at
Ethan he's like but go go get a rope and
then P I'll let you I'll let you take
the story he gets the rope and then play
from here go ahead Rob just play from
right here there's a a deer Fell in This
is an aspin go ahead watch this okay
look that's Mario walking by the way
that Lake he steps on that he's going
down he's going that's the deer listen
one last old throw one last that's
that's Mario screaming no no that's the
deer screaming watch this he got it with
one throw at him need help that's Al how
the hell did Mario he's on the ledge
he's on the edge of of the ice that's
the most dangerous part good job
dude well now we know how your
sound look at this
dude oh it's amazing Mario
Bro the City of Aspen needs to send a
letter to Mario agular watch this fre
the deer is about to die can't get up
he's trying to stand up on the ice and
his hes so watch Mario does as if he's
done this 50 times I'm watching this
video a local support you know guys
coming from the city and then I look at
the camera I'm like that's
Mario dude look at this a gual cowboy
like rest of it and you can tell the
deer trust him at this point they have a
relationship they have a
relationship dude watch this bro watch
this slow down you're good let me guess
Hunter he runs into fence yeah deer
shoots him 3 minutes after by the way so
so that's the day off the hero I know
this sounds
I know this sounds like a what I'm
telling you right now like it's straight
out of a movie so that's Mario the next
morning I get up no joke to walk outside
and my dad's like go see what's outside
Rob I just sent you the Tweet pull up
the tweet I just
sent that's the one watch that one turn
the audio on look at this look at this
look at these this is the next day oh I
saw this video yeah they're all here
look at these guys surrounded by
Elks almost looks like a they came to
pay respect to their Godfather Mario
from the
movie Leave the World
Behind but it also looks like every
Hunter's dream oh look at all that meat
is that James Earl Jones Voice or is
that youle by the way there's 200 of
them outside easily they gave a prayer
they saluted at Mario they made a
certain unique chant and just saying we
just want to thank on behalf of the elk
in the deer Community thank you Mario I
I don't think people I don't think
people realize Mario has never taken a
rope and lasto in his life he threw it
in one shot if he doesn't get it in that
one shot that deer is dead I don't even
know if Mario's ever even been around a
deer no dude and then mind you he's on
the edge of the water which is the most
dangerous and then he's like Ethan come
over here come add to this danger by the
way if they go in It's A Wrap they don't
know how to get out of that let me tell
you something all right I'm not I'm not
going to say any you know Mario just
became a father Yes okay uh young
Gabriel's how old is Gabriel now maybe
like 6 months less than six months less
than six months I don't know when a man
and woman after giving a child when you
go again but when Mario's wife Barbie
sees that video I'm just saying there
might be another baby in 9 months it's
already I'm just
saying you know what lines you can
officially use on your girl I love it
when you save Deer I save Bambi baby
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you me Bambi and Barbie what do you
mean when she sees the video she's
pregnant
again don't rumors I'm joking anyways
hey all right it's good to be back Mario
you're amazing ASP Aspen if you're
listening send this man a letter
thanking him for what he did to the deer
in Aspen folks uh Happy New Year to you
you already heard what I said at the
beginning of it on future looks bride
this is going to be a very weird year
represent the gear of future looks bride
go to the gym wear it put that hat on
tell everybody I believe it's all going
to work itself out don't let anybody put
the fear in you this is going to be a
very very special opportunistic Year
we're looking forward to doing big
things here together with you cannot
wait to see you guys on the next episode
which is when Rob are we doing it
Thursday or tomorrow Thursday is it a
special guest or is it just home team
Thursday uh Thursday we do have a guest
we do have a guest perfect we'll see you
guys on Thursday podcast take care
everybody happy New Year bye- bye bye-
bye bye-bye Happy New
Year